>> Google I/O 2016
Machine learning:  Google's
Vision
>> Good morning, welcome to day
three of Google I/O and what
should be a fun conversation
about machine learning and
artificial intelligence.  My
time is Tom Simon.  And like all
of you I have been hearing
recently about the growing power
of machine learning.  We have
seen striking results come out
of academic and research lab and
they move is quickly into the
hands of developers who have
been used to make products and
services and companies.  I'm
joined by three people who can
tell us about the new technology
an the capabilities it brings
come out into the chorld.  They
are Chen who  Aparna, Jeff dean
who leads the Google brain
research group here in  mountain
view, and John Giannandrea who
is head of search and machine
intelligence.  We are going to
talk for about 30 minutes and
there will be time for questions
from the floor.  John, why
don't we start with you, you
could set the scene for us.
Artificial intelligence and
machine learning are not brand
new concepts.  They have been
around a long time but we are
certainly  hearing more about
them.  Large and small companies
are i nvesting and there is
excitement.  You can get a large
number of people come to a talk
about this early in the morning
so what's going
on in?
>> JOHN GIANNANDREA: I think
the last few years we have seen
extraordinary results in fields
that hadn't really moved the
needle for many years like
speech recognition and image
understanding.  The error rates
are falling dramatically mostly
because of advancements in deep
learning.  I think these
techniques are not new.  People
have been using networks for
many, many years, but a
combination of events over the
last few years has made them
more effective and caused us to
get them into the hands of
developers.
People talk in terms of AI
winters and things like this.  I
think we are kind of in an AI
spring where we are seeing
remarkable progress across a
huge number of fields.
>> TOM SIMONITE: How long have
you worked in artificial
intelligence.
>> JOHN GIANNANDREA: We started
investing heavily four years a
go.  We got serious about our
investments about four years ago
and getting organized to do
things ultimately resulted in
the release of things like t
enser flow, which Jeff's team
worked on.
>> TOM SIMONITE: We will talk
about that later for sure.  A
parna, give us perspective from
the view of someone who builds
plucks.  John says this
technology has become more p
owerful and accurate and u
seful.  Does that open up new
horizons for you when you are
thinking about what you could
build?
>> APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Absolu
tely.  For me, these are great
as a technology, but as a means
to an end they are powerful tool
kits but to solve real
problems.  And for us as
building products and you guys
too, there is two ways that
machine learning changes the
game.  One is that it can turbo
charge existing use cases, that
is existing problems like, you
know, speech recognition by
dramatically changing technical
components that power the
product.  If you are building a
wire to enable a system.  As
soon as it dropped we saw the
usage go up.  So the product
gets more useable as machine
learning improves the underlying
engine.  Same thing with
translation.  As translation
gets better, Google translate,
if scales to 100 plus languages
and photos is a great example.
You have heard someone talk
about it too that as soon as you
have better image understanding
the photo labeling gets better
and I can organize photos.
That's one way we have seen, but
I think the second way that's
personally far more exciting to
see is where it can unlock new
product use cases, so turbo
charging existing use cases is
one thing but where can you see
problems that really weren't
thought of as AI or data
problems.  And thanks to mobile,
3 billion phones a lot of the
real world problems are turning
into AI problems, like
transportation, health, that's
exciting too.
>> TOM SIMONITE: So we can make
computers, we have had this
experience of where you have a
clear idea of what  you are
trying to do but it feels like
the software is doing everything
to stop you.  Maybe that's a
form of artificial intelligence
too.  Can you make more seamless
experience that's make life
easier?
>> APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: In
this case, again, one of the
things to
think about is how do you make
sure as you build products how
do you make sure your interface
scales with intelligence.  The
UI needs to be proportional to
AI.  I can't believe I said some
oud pseudoformula in front of
Jeff dean, but I think that's
important to make sure that the
UI scales with the AI.
>> TOM SIMONITE: And, Jeff, for
people like Aparna that are
building products to do that, we
need this translation step.
Google brain, there a research
group that work on  fundamental
question in this field but you
build this infrastructure that
you are inventing from scratch
that makes it possible to use
this stuff.
>> JEFF DEAN: Yes, I think,
obviously in order to make
progress on these kinds of
problems, it's really important
to be able to try lots of
experiments and do that as
quickly as you can.  There is a
very sort of fundamental
difference between having an
experiment take a few hours
versus something that takes six
weeks.  It's just a very
different model of doing s
cience, and so one of the things
pee work on  -- we work on is
trying to build scalable systems
that are flexible and easy to
express new kinds of machine
learning ideas.  That's how
tenser flow came about.  It's
our internal research vehicle
but robust enough to take
something you have done and done
lots of experiments on, and
then when you get something that
works well, you move that into
a production environment, on p
hones, data centers on RTPUs we
announced a few days ago, and
that seamless transition from
research to like putting things
into real products is what we
are all about.
>> TOM SIMONITE: So tenser flow
is this very flexible package,
it's very valuable to Google,
you are building a lot on top of
it, but you are giving it away
for free.  Have you thought this
through?  Isn't this something
you should be keeping closely
held?
>> JEFF DEAN: There was a
little bit of debate internally.
We decided to open source it
and it has a nice patch  Apache
license which means you can take
it and do what you want with
it, and the reason we did that
is several fold.  One is we
think it's a good way of making
research ideas and machine
learning propagate more quickly
throughout the community.
People can publish existing of
something they have done and
people can pick up that thing
and reproduce those people's
results or build on them, and,
you know F. you look on github
there are 1500 repos fors that
mention tenser flow and only
five are from Google.  So it's
people doing all kinds of stuff
with  tenser
flow.
>> TOM SIMONITE: Where is this
going?  I imagine now that t
enser flow is mostly used with
people who are quite familiar
with machine learning, but
ultimately the way I hear people
talk about machine learning is
it's just going to be used by
everyone, everywhere.  So can
developers who don't have much
of a background in this stuff
pick it up yet?  Is that
possible?
>> JEFF DEAN: Yes, I think
actually there is a whole set of
ways in which people can take
advantage of machine learning.
One is as a fundamental machine
learning researcher you want to
develop new algorithms and that
will be a relatively small
fraction of people in the world.
As new algorithms and models
are developed to solve
particular problems, those
models can be applied in lots of
different things.  If you look
at the use of machine learning
in the diabetic retinopathy
stuff, that's a similar problem
to a lot of other problems where
you are trying to look at an
image and detect some part
that's unusual.  We have a
similar problem of finding text
in street view images so we can
read the text.
That looks similar to a model to
detect disease parts of an eye,
just different training data,
but the same model.  So I think
the broader set of models will
be accessible to more and more
people, and then there is even
an easier way where you don't
really need much machine
learning knowledge at all and
that is to use pre trained APIs.
You can use our Cloud vision
API or speech API simply, just
give us an image and we give you
back good stuff and as part of
the tenser flow open source we
released, for example, an
inception model that does image
classification that's the same
model that under lies Google
photos.
>> TOM SIMONITE: So it will be
possible for someone, maybe they
are an experienced builder of
apps but don't know much about
machine learning they could have
an idea and use the building
blocks together.
>> JEFF DEAN: One of the
republicans tenser flow has
taken off is tutorials in
tenser flow are quite good in i
dentifying six or seven
different kinds of models in
machine learning and showing
people how they work, stepping
through both the machine
learning going on underneath and
how you express them in tenser
flow.  It's been pretty well
received.
>> TOM SIMONITE: I think we
have seen in the past that when
a new platform of mode or
interaction comes forward, we
have to experiment for some time
before we figure out what
works, right?  And sometimes
when we look back, we might
think, oh, those first
generation mobile apps were
clunky and not so smart.  How
are we going with that process
here?  We are starting to have
to understand how, what types of
interaction work?
>> APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: And I
think that's, it's one of the
things that's not intuitive when
you start out.  You rush out
into a new area like we have all
done.  One experience when we
started working on Google now,
one thing we realized is it's
really important to make sure
that depending on the product
domain, some then of the these
user black box is systems, like
all you need to right, I pay
attention should refresh to what
myself because we the data call
I'm internally displaying as
has changed the wow! .  So you
go there, To it refreshes WDH
ratio.  As soon, as this you is
when say it there is is yellow
delight because you know data is
pending fall magical, it's
moments, right, not but s then
ify youn getc it wrong, there is
a high cost to the user.  So to
give you ed yet.  Then when the
application logic finally sinks
,an maybe three example days
later, in who cares, Google
search it let's up saydates you
the model again search, and for
if you're Justin really
Timberlake still and we got a
there slightly less relevant
answer, not a big, deal, it's
going to re but then if   the
assistant told   refreshyou
itself to. sit in  the The views
, represent the car model go and
drive nothing to else. the
airport and you missed your
flight, what  the hell?  Right,
so I think it's important to get
Of course, the temporary U
ratioI states.
I was on the application
two minutes ago, it says the
list is there.  You fetch the
list much users.  Fetch the data
, if the user liked this.
Multiple workers, so after
refreshing user data from
network, the other one sends the
user stats, and like you went
back, you want to read the list
of users from the disc, so you
are trying to load it from the
disc, but the problem is your
background turns out busy trying
to make a network request.
Like this is so bad because you
know you won't be able to access
it, but the network you don't
know,
and you're making the user wait
for no reason.  The solution for
this is very simple, you just
have different queues, you
cannot just create a queue for
every type of run, but usually
at least you should have one for
your network related stuff and
one for your local access.  Even
for local access, you probably
just, those things are under
200, 300 milliseconds, very fast
.  So once we do this, we have
these tests because you want to
get data, they get in different
queues.  So even if the network
is slow, locally everything is
working.  This is what we call
applications should work offline
, everything just works, then
you're trying to sync it later
on.  So we'll look at the other
section, how you optimize for
the next billion.  Next billion
looks like this.
So this you need to translate
your application.  If you want
people to use it in other areas
of the world, you want it to be
translated.  So you translate
the application, you translate
your assets because you may have
text there, and you also
translate your purchases so they
can spend -- their in app
purchases so they can spend
money.  This is not completely
true.  Translate ing is not the
right word.  The right thing you
should do is localize.  So
localize your application.
Don't just translate it because
let's say you have an
application about the family
communicate ing with their kids,
on the place or page, if you
have American Family, you put
Indonesian family, or the
Chinese family, you should
localize your assets also in the
application because this is
what will make sense to that
user.  Every culture has their
differences, and if you want to
make the best of localization,
this is what you should be doing
.  The other thing is text free
layouts.  The way you can do
this is really useful.  For
example, if you're a message ing
app, if you just want to say
send, don't say send.  Put check
marks.  If it's red, put
double-check marks.  This helps
you so you don't need to
translate it, it's fairly global
, your users learn it, and even
if your application is not
message ing something, the
literature rate may not be very
good in that area, this will
help more users be able to use
your application.  If you have
no WiFi, don't just put wa no
WiFi, people learn this.  If you
use the material team and stuff
, user lands your application
and actual knows it, this is
very important.  The other thing
is about adaptive content
fetching.  Let's say it's an
application that shows photos,
and this is the same UI.  It
looks the same.  Of course the
one on the right is kind of low
quality.  But the one on the
left is 100% J peculiar
JPEG and the right is
10% JPEG.  Almost one-tenth of
it in terms of size and it looks
okay.  Of course you don't want
to show a lower color image to
your users, but you need to
think about, they either see the
lower quality image or a blank
screen.  There's a big
difference between seeing a
blank screen and a low quality
image.  Bonus points, you can
refresh the content so you
realize the network is not very
good, you refresh the lower
quality image and once you
figure out someone else network
recovers, you refresh those
images, especially if it is free
, you should do that.  Like the
connectivity API, it tells you
if the network is metered or not
.  So I want to give you some
examples what we do at Google
about this.  For example, if
you're using Google+ in the
settings there's a way to say
okay, data usage.  If you're
even living in the United
States, you
don't appreciate it because you
have the data, but the rest of
the people pay premiums for
their data, so they're very,
very cautious about it.  So you
put the settings like that.  And
in Google+, these are what we
actually do.  If the network is
fast, we fetch a high quality EG
.  Appears the network
JPEG.  As the
network goes slower, so like
instead of user seeing a blank,
the user sees some data, they
get a better user experience.
We also educate use ers.  This
is also important.  What does it
mean to conservative data, why
don't you always do it?  Like
why waste my data?  Users click
on there and we explain to them,
this is what it means to save
data.  Another part is adaptive
behavior.  It's very common in
applications to have like auto
playing games or auto playing
videos.  What you should do is
is, okay, at this point my user
is showing my feed, is the
network fast?  If the network is
fast, just go auto play the
video.  But if the network is
slow, don't do that.  Just put
the play button.  Don't waste
the network just because they
may want to watch that video.
That's a bad thing for your
users.  And I have good network
here, so I will play this video.
>> Yes.
irl.
.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: For
example, this is what we do in
YouTube, right?  In YouTube, if
you go to call the settings,
there's an answer that says
auto.  Essential what it does,
Essentially what it does, by
checking the network quality, we
adjust your bit rate.  You
probably don't even notice, but
but it takes time to
implement.  Google spghts dash
and streaming.  All you have to
do is use this library and let
it handle the different network
protocols.  Of course also your
server side needs to support it.
This is important.  Okay.  So
another use case, we'll look at
Uncle Bob.  So this guy goes to
work every morning, takes the
bus, Google bus, reads his news
on the bus, does the same thing
on the way back.  This happens
all the time.  But what also
happens all the time is this,
he's seeing a loading dialogue
when he tries to read his
network, read his news, because
there's another of 0 people in
the same bus trying to use the
same internet connection and
there's -- there's another 60
people in the same bus trying to
use the same internet
connection and there's other
cars there and it gets congested
and no one gets a good
experience.  How can we fix this
?  The good news is that this
guy goes to work at the same
time every morning
morning, he wakes up at 6:30,
no-brainer, set an alarm.
Right?  We can set an alarm to
prepare the content for him, and
also maybe he leaves work at
like 5:30 every night.  Set an
alrm for that and prepare the
content so that they get some
content when they open the
application.  The way we can do
this, help you wake up your
application every morning 6:30
so you can prefetch your content
.  Let's say we implemented, all
these users have a good
experience every morning at 6:30
they get the latest news and
they are happy.  But then we get
more users and more users make
this request at 6:30 and then
this is what happens, your Cloud
goes down.  You know what comes
up when your Cloud goes down?
Your system admin.  Bad guy
slept at like 4:30 in the
morning, you woke him up at 6:30
with a pager.  It's a real
story actually
actually, topts see a
podcast from a provider, they
say there's a bug with Android
phones every morning at this
time we are getting so many
requests.  Turns out it was an
application like this.  So we
don't do that.  How do we fix
this?  Super-simple.  So instead
of just waking up at 6:30, you
randomize it, wake up between
6:00 and 7:00 and then you wake
up each application in that
random time.  And then
you're happy.  But then we are
unhappy.  Seriously, 2016.  Come
o how do we do this?  We do
this with job scierl or you can
use GCR network manager for the
older API versions.  We want to
do this with job schedule er,
you create a job, you say okay,
this is my service, you say we
want the un   unmetered network,
there's no reason to cache the
data if user is going to pay for
it.  Then we say, okay, start
the earliest around 6:30 and
then make it only if the device
is idle.  And you say if it's
only charging.  Like these are
all optional things.  Say all
right, these are all optional
things that you can do depending
on your use case.  What does
this override deadline mean?
The idea here is that let's say
we have this thing and the user
forgot to charge their phone, so
they'll never wake up in the
morning, but what will happen is
it will be waiting there
sitting idle, maybe he'll go to
work and then they will plug in
their phone and then fetch the
content.  It's already past,
like we missed the deadline, why
would you do this?  We tell the
job schedule er, hey, if you
cannot do this until 7:30, wake
me up.  So what we can do is
when the job is started, you can
simply check, okay, did I get
the dateline?  Did the dateline
date
deadline?  Did the deadline
expire?  If the deadline expired
, this is why I was woken up.
If the connection is limited, if
it is not, I don't want it on
this job anymore.  Or if you can
say something like if the
battery is charging or is like
at least 75%, otherwise, I will
not run this job.  So this
completely depends on your use
case, but you get the idea.
Like I think we provide enough
APIs on the framework side to be
able to implement these things.
And it's not hard.  And your
user receives a really good user
experience.  It's important.
So for example, in YouTube, you
you can         can go ahead and
download the video for offline.
At home you watch the TV
series, you download it, and
while on the bus you can watch
it.  Or in maps, like recently I
was on vacation outside the
country and I just downloaded he
the area on Google maps and
even though I didn't have data
there, I could use my phone to
navigate.  It was so nice.  So
these are like little things
that make a huge user experience
difference
.  Another example of prefetch
ing, this is slightly different
but this is what we do in
Google+.  Whenever there is a
new post, we show like little
touch button that you can tap to
refresh.  So in there what
happens behind the scenes is we
detect there are new posts, we
let the user know, and if the
user taps, we are going to go
ahead and fetch the content and
then refresh the UI.  Now, we
changed this a little bit.  This
is what we did.  When we did a
new post now, we actually go
ahead and fetch it because users
in the application with new
posts, they want to see, we are
fairly comfortable that they
want that content, so we fetch
it for them.  Then we leapt the
user know that there's new
content of the look, we don't
just refresh it because they
might be doing something else
and it will be a bad user
experience.  Instead, we just
notify the user there is new
content.  And if they tap, we'll
refresh the data.  Now, the
difference between these two
user experience flaws is the
first one takes around three
seconds, the second one takes .3
seconds.  This is a 9X
difference, just change the
order of two operations, a huge
user experience improvement with
very, very little.  It's
important.  But if you're doing
prefetching, it's a very
dangerous thing.  It's really
good for users, but it also
might be really bad.  So you
have to be careful.  The first
thing you should be doing is
balance for the available
storage.  Just don't fill up
their phone, especially in the
rest of the world, the phones
have lower memory, so you
shouldn't be filling it up with
prefetched content.  Or if you
are going to fetch some data
that's expensive, let user know
like, you know, I want to do
this update, provide them the
settings for these things.  Like
these people are really, really
, like they care about their
data, so you should give them
options and they will use them.
The other part is, so I always
get this thing rs oh, now the
Android devices have 3 gigabytes
of memory, we don't need to
care about it.  Wrong.  The
screen has got a lot bigger, so
we need to use a lot more memory
and better quality.  We try to
run many more applications
because it's best for the user.
So always measure your memory.
Like in the latest versions of
Android, this is so easy, you
tap on a button.  Remember
before you need to get the
memory from DDMS and then
convert it and it was a mess.
Now in Android Studio, you just
click on a button, it opens in
this nice UI and you know
there's the usual suspects there
.  So just click on that, it
will show you all this.  You can
check, okay, why am I retaining
this object?  The coolest
thing, I love this thing, you
can just right click on the
selected title.  Like how cool
is that?  You know what you
have, this is so much faster
than what you were able to do
before.  So we are always
spending time making these tools
better and should take
advantage of them.
So you guys have seen in N
we're spending a lot of time in
battery life.  This is very
important for us.  We cannot do
this without your help.  So in N
, we also introduce this new
feature called data saver where
user can say, you know what,
iment       I want to limit the
application data for the
background apps, they don't get
any data unless the network is
limited.  But if you're a good
application, the user white
whitelist you
might whitelist you, so
you'll get the data while your
competitor doesn't.  And it only
works in metered networks.  So
we only block you if we have a
reason to do so.  So how to use
it   it?  The connectivity
manager now has this new
API that can say is the active
network metered?  If it is
metered, you can get the
background status, like if it is
enable ed or if you are
whitelist          whitelisted
or you are disabled.  So the
idea is even if the user put
data saver on but you are
whitelisted, you should still be
cautious about okay, I don't
want to spend too much data, I
have use            , you don't
need to send it now, you can
send it later.  Going to some
offline use cases and I want you
to start thinking about, okay,
how can I make my application
more offline?  So one use case,
the first time we give it a year
ago, people said okay, for
commercial app, there's a place
where people buy products, I
cannot make it offline, which is
true, you cannot make it
offline because the price
changes.  There's no way you'll
tell them, hey, you bought this
for $500 and then one day later
you charge them $700.  You
cannot do that.  That would be
rude.  But there are still
things you can do.  In your
application, like product
information, when you buy
something, when I'm going buy
something          something,
like I go to the same page again
and again and again, this
happens, this is user behavior.
So optimize for that.  Keep the
user data.  Let them search.  I
will probably search for the
same products, let them do local
search.  Remember when we
talked about having the proper
model?  It helps them here
because you can let them search
locally plus to let them know I
am showing the local.  If they
go to the product page, show
some sort of animation saying
you can't buy this right now,
I'm fetching the price, and then
when the price comes, you show
it to them.  So you don't block
the user, but for important data
, you just
don't show it, or show it grade
out           grayed out.  I
know.  But think about this.
Another example is a message ing
app.  So say Jenny and Michael.
This is fine, pick me up at
7:00.  Okay.  We'll meet at
7:00.  But around 6:30, Michael
realizes that hey, his dog is
sick, he doesn't want to leave
the dog home.  So he says hey,
Jenny, my dog is sick.  Well,
how about you come over, we hang
out at home.  That's so cool.
Unless, you know, well, the mess
sang couldn't be sent for
whatever reason.  Failed.  So as
a developer, I let the user
know, you're actually not done,
because Michael, well, he wants
to call his vet to get some tips
and stuff, so he already left
the application.  So Michael did
not know that he could not send
the message.  Michael couldn't
know that he didn't send the
message, Jenny never saw the
message
, and this is Jenny      Jenny's
heart, it's broken because of
you.
(laughter)
.
What can you do?  You
can do something better.  It's
important          important.
If you like the dating profile
and you couldn't send it to the
user now, it's fine, it's not
that important.  Message
Messaging application, instant
message ing application, you
have some responsibilities.  So
if you couldn't send the message
and you know the user didn't
see t let them know.  Show a
notification, because you
already know that user is not in
your activity, you already know
that they did not see the
message.  So instead, show the
notification, Michael calls his
girlfriend and they're a happy
couple thanks to you.  Another
thing that you can like further
improve the user experience is
you can always let them know,
like if you're in the screen,
they're message ing, if you know
there's no internet connection,
just put it.  If you're
listening for internet
connection in N, you only
receive that broadcast if you're
in the application, like don't
register for that broadcast, you
can try, it's not going on work
.  But your application, you can
still use the connectivity
measure and broadcast.  So the
other example, if you like TV
schedule application, of course
they cannot watch TV offline,
but you can do some stuff, you
can let them click on a button
and schedule an larm.  Right?
There are still things you can
do because you can implant this
all within the device without
requiring network communication.
So the idea is if you start
thinking about what can I do off
line, you will find really,
really good use cases and it's
going differ he be yait your
application.  So even though we
are talking about this, we say
the next billion users, it helps
the users, everybody around the
world.  It's not only for them.
Okay.  So I want to quickly go
through this
, you synchronize the data.
Update the model and synchronize
the data.  How do I do this?
Molecular scientist is work og
this problem, they don't have to
sfl it, there's something
called operational transforming
transforming, things
like Google Docs users, a bunch
of things I don't know, other
articles, but you don't need
them.  What we apply is the
Pareto principal.  We'll do
Pareto
principle, we'll do 20% of the
work, get 80% of the benefits
and run away.  You have
something a user likes, when
your user likes t marketers like
it, you update the model.  But
what happens is next time like
there was another request
running and it fetches a list
again, overwrites what you have
put there.  That's a bad problem
.  How do you solve this?  Very
easy.  You add another field
that you only modify locally, so
it's yours      yours.  I call
this like ed local here.  So
when you want to check if user
liked the post, you do this, hey
, you update that field.  When
you fetch the feed, it doesn't
overwrite because the field
doesn't exist on the server side
.  And if you want to get, like
when you're putting the UI, if
you want to check if the user
liked this, it's simple, you
check if there's a local value,
show it.  Otherwise, use the
value from the server.  Very
simple, super-easy to implement
and it gives you most of the
benefits.  So another example,
let's say you're fetching posts,
posts have been deleted on the
server.  Tell your server guys,
let them send you the list of
delete ed poassmentsz it's so
easy for them to do.  This way
you can locally cache everything
, show everything locally, and
if something has been delete ed
on the serve,        server,
you'll eventually get updated
about it.  This is easy for them
to do.  If you get another
example, you can be sending the
server, hey, I have the post,
you make a call to get new posts
.  Now the server cannot send
you which items from the trench
have been deleted -- now the
server can send you which items
from the trench have been
deleted.  I know there's a clash
, you want other people topped
the work.  I have a perfect rest
API, so you make 25 requests
just to fetch a feed.  Don't let
them do that.  Like fight for T
it's important
it   it.  It's important they
provide you the right APIs for
your application.  Another case
here, I was trying to update the
profile page, I have two
different
, one changes favorite color,
one changes name.  How do you
solve the conflicts?  Add a
version        version.  Now
your data is versioned, so when
you make a request, client says
okay, change the favorite color
to this one on top of version 10
and then the server can say
okay, since this version, I can
apply this diff and do it or
decide whether you want to,
maybe you don't want them to do
that.  The thing is it will
happen very, very rarely and you
will be handling that case.  So
these won't overwrite each
other.  If you start versioning
your objects, your value objects
, you get this nice thing where
like hey, you made it fetch, you
made the request to fetch posts
, some of them were updated,
server already knows you told
the server I have these items
with these versions.  The stuff
that has been changed, they can
tell hey, hey, these are the
posts that have been updated and
here is their new data.  You
want a request, you get all of
the diff.  I'm not telling you
to do things this way, this is
just a way of doing things, it
is very simple and it is
effective.  Okay.  So if you
want to read more about this
topic, you can go learn about
multiple version control, like
maybe some really really
important learn about operation,
transform, if this is really
important for you to do, like
multiple clients, changing the
same data.  These problems, you
just need to go ahead and check
them.  I'll go through some
quick tips and tricks
tricks, little bite size
information.  As I said before,
when we talk about network,
design your API for your client.
Like I have a perfect risk API
.  No, it doesn't matter.  The
perfect API is the one that my
user experience fit the best.
Like this is what you want.  So
do it.  Tell them to do it for
you.  But your API should be for
your application.  Whatever you
can do on the server, do it on
the server.  Like if they can
pass metadata, anything that
will help you, do it there,
because it's much easier to
scale than the tiny device you
have in your pocket.  And one
more thing you do is batch your
requests.  Now, again and again
we say battery life is very
important, data is very
important.  If you batch your
requests, the battery life will
improve a lot.  Job schedule er
does it for you.  So just use
job schedule error GCN network
manager.  We will love you.
These are good things.  For
example, this is an example,
like a bad API.  This is a
terrible API.  It gives me a
user, a name and filter UR
URL.  I have no idea what that
filter URL represents.  You put
in a grid, the filter, it starts
moving, because you doan know
how big the image is.  You put
something random there, the
image turned out to be a really
weird one.  It's terrible for
the user.  It's very easy to fix
.  Tell your sender to send
send      server
to send you are the height and
width.  They want to have the
final size.  If your server
sends it to you, you have the
final size.  You can even send,
there's ways to calculate on the
server side instead of the
device.  They send you the pal
let picture                 cr p
alette of the picture, it has a
same background color.  This
user experience is very
important.  So to sum up
everything, the main goal here
is you architecture your
application for the user
experience, they can be in the
United States, Indonesia, China,
it doesn't matter.  The
important sthing the user
experience
thing is the user
experience is your important.
Local model, don't keep things
in hatch maps.  Put it on disc.
When you write your application
, don't think, okay, now I get
this data from the server and I
update this UI and the user
clicks on this, I make this
other request.  Don't do that.
Think about I have the data on
the disc, that's what I show to
the user, my user reacts, I have
some logic to update the data
on the disc and I show it all
the time.  Some other
application logic that tries to
synchronize the data with the
server.  It makes it a lot
easier.  Decouple.  You should
decouple these things.  The part
that's related to the UI and
the disc, they know each other,
you have an application logic
that talks to the network.  When
you de   decouple things, it
makes it a lot easier to test,
but don't over     overdo it.
Architecture stuff, hey, I
created interface and interface
for the factories and the
interface of the factory
factories.  Don't do that.  This
is still a form.  If you look
at the framework code, we still
write it as we write C.  You
don't have to write it like that
.  Use it if it makes your
application better.  But like
don't overarchitect.  It's still
a mobile form, we are trying to
run many, many applications on
the same device.  And even if
the device has four or eight
course, most of the time only
one or two of those codes are
really capable of doing anything
, plus we try to keep them low
and not         or not run them
at all to save battery.  Act
early.  This is important.  In a
previous job I worked, if you
have this kind of technical
depth, it's really, really hard
to pay.  So the sooner you start
, the better it is.  Something
to remember, know your enemies.
Network is unreliable.  You
don't want to be doing a network
request.  Every time you should
make a network request, you
should feel uncomfortable.  And
know your friends.  Disc is your
friend.  It's very reliable.
If the disc is broken, the phone
is already broken, so you don't
need to worry about it.  So is
your friend, it's actually your
best friend.  Thank you.
(applause)
.
I have like two and a
half minutes for questions.
Maybe I can take one or two
questions, and then I will be
outside there if there are more.
>> My question is, in
the like application where you
had the heart, what's the need
to have the yellow heart to show
that you    you -- couldn't you
just show the red one right
away and then do your stuff in
the background?  Yig yipg the
problem
>> YIGIT BOYAR: The
problem with showing the red one
is if you can't send t user
does not know.  Maybe for a
dating application, you can show
the red one, but it's better to
have two states, like the
example, you first send a
message, it's gray     gray,
they send it to server, and it's
check mark when they send it to
the other user, so it's good to
let them know.  They learn
about these things.
>> Thank you.
>> Sync it up eumpsed
to be a                 used to
be a great tool to do offline
apps.  Is it still one and is
the job scale er maybe a better
one in.
>> YIGIT BOYAR:
Actually I think starting, I'm
not sure which one, sync it up
actually uses job schedule er
behind the scenes.  I personally
find job schedule er much
better API, a lot more
convenient to use, but you can
use sync it up.  That's fine.
>> Like the same
question, so sync it up, we are
in the emerging market.  It
probably sinks
probably syncs it up with the
content provider.  The
background creates a lot of
problem for us because of
our virtual cat, and we want to
place it on the on the man and
the                    ottoman
and the cat should stay fixed in
the environment as we move
around it and ideally it would
even interact with the
environment a little bit.  Maybe
the cat jumps down from the
ottoman to the floor or jumps up
on the table, just a little bit
of playfulness.  So easy enough
.  All right.  We've got a
couple of things going on here
that we need to cover first.
We've got the camera feed.  So
the camera is the 2D projection
of the 3D world onto an image
plane as seen through the lens,
and it comes in at 30 frames a
second on Tango devices.  So as
I move my camera around the
world      world, I might get a
different view of the sofa, of
the fireplace
fireplace, of the TV and the
table, and that 3D view is
compressed onto this 2D image
plane, and it's in color.  In
the real world when you're
walking around, you don't have
to worry about much beyond this,
right?  Physics takes care of
it.  Physics is awesome.  And
the light comes in, and you just
get different perspectives
based on how you walk around.
But now we're talking about
compositing a virtual character
into this physical scene, and it
gets a little bit more
complicated.  The cat doesn't
actually exist in the real world
.  So to understand how we
render this cat as if it's in
the real world, let's forget
about the real world entirely
for just a moment and explore
this problem.  So say instead of
in the real world we've got a
virtual cat and we want to
render it on the screen of our
device, we want to place it
approximately 2 meters in front
of the device and hold it fixed
and just move around it.  For
those who are familiar with
building 3D games, this is very,
very similar to how a camera
system in a standard rendering
engine works.  We're going to
place our object in a coordinate
frame called the world frame of
the game, and then we're going
on render it relative
to render it
relative to the frame of our
camera as we move around it.  At
the start we'll view the cat
from the left and at the end of
our motion round of the cat we
want to see it from the right,
and it always stays fixed.  So
with Tango, this is exactly what
we'll do, just instead of
programmatically setting the
transform of the camera as it
moves in the world, we'll get it
from
the Tango device itself.  Tango
has a couple of coordinate
frames I'll talk about that are
relevant for this.  So the world
frame for Tango is remitted as
start of service, and it's
wherever you started with the
device.  The device frame
is wherever you currently are
with the device.  If I start
here, that defines start of
service.  If I ask for the
transform between start of
service and device, when device
is here, it will give me sort of
two meters.  So now to show
this a little bit, I'm going to
give a demo of what this looks
like in action.
So here I've got a completely
virtual world, and I've got this
cat, we'll call him Mittens, I
guess.  And as I move
around Mittens, he stays fixed
in the virtual world      world.
But he's not tied to my
physical space in any way.  I
can make him walk, but it's just
on a plane that exists in space
, and he can also, I guess, paw
in the camera when I get close
to him.
(applause)
.
It gets better, I
promise.
(laughter).
All right.  We'll go
back.
So to make this a little more
concrete, I want to just show
the calls that you need to make
in our APIs to be able to do
this.  So Tango provides a
function called get pose at time
, and you can pass it, the base
coordinate frame that you would
like as well as the target
like and it will return you the
transform at that point in time.
So here you can see I'm
defining a frame pair where I
want to ask where is the device
relative to the start of service
.  So my base frame is start of
service, and my target frame is
device, and I say get me the
transform at time T, where maybe
time is now.  And the time
stamp actually turns out to be
really important when you're
trying to do things like
composites onto an image because
the camera takes an image at a
very particular point in time,
so that's something that will
be         we'll be coming back
to to make sure that the cat is
well registered with the
environment when we go to
composit it.  But overall this
is pretty simple, right?  You
can just at any time ask for
where the device is in the world
, and boom, you know, you've got
a handheld AR cat viewer.  So
it's not exact what will we're
looking for
what we're looking for
.  The goal is to place the
virtual cat on the ottoman in
the physical world.  The first
thing you might think of doing
is just taking the RGB image ask
we're just going to slap the
cat onto the RGB image and it
will be fine, we'll just use
that as the background, but it's
not going on look quite right.
This slide demonstrates it, but
I'll go to a demo again just to
make it a little more clear.
Now we've got Mittens, but
he's not looking super-awesome
super-awesome.
He's just floating in space in
front of me.  And here I really
would rather he be on the ground
, so that's what we're going to
work to do.  But if you would
build an application like, say,
a sun with planets orbiting
around it, this could be an
appropriate visualization, but
for Mittens it's all wrong.  So
we'll go back to our slides and
we'll see that it is really,
really wrong.  All right.
Really, I hadn't looked at that
image in a while, so I like it.
All right.  So what can we do
to fix this?  There are a couple
of things that we can try.
Before we go down this road,
though, it's worth mentioning
again that perfect augmented
reality is largely an uninvolved
problem, so we're going to talk
about some things to make the
cat look better       better,
but it's not going to be perfect
.  I've learned to manage
expectations, so you'll see me
do this throughout the talk, but
we're going to get better, and
we'll talk about the limitations
in detail at the end.  So with
that public service announcement
out of the way, how far down
the road can we go with Tango?
Step 1 is that we can tie the
cat into the environment using
Tango's depth-sensing APIs.  So
I mentioned before that the
device doesn't just understand
its position in space, it also
understands the geometry of the
environment.  So maybe we can
use the Tango device to actually
decide where to place the cat
to recognize surfaces in the
environment and then we can tie
it to the floor at the correct
size and scale.  And Tango
provides exactly these
capabilities through our support
library ies to developers.  You
can essentially ask for a given
pixel in an image, give me the
point and normal in the world
frame of that pixel, and then we
can place the cat there.  And
to show this, you can see that
this is the code needed to
compute that point and normal in
space.  So the first thing we
do is we need to get the
relative pose of the depth to
the RGB image.  This is a little
bit subtle.  So as you're
walking around, we're taking RGB
images all the time, but we're
also firing the depth camera,
but they're not actually taken
at the exact same time.  There's
a little bit of an offset there
.  So if I naively took the
point Cloud at the time stamp of
the RGB camera and just select
ed a point, it would be off a
little bit.  It wouldn't look
correct.  What I need to do is
actually transform the depth
information into the frame of
the RGB camera.  Here what you
can see is we're calling a
support function that says
calculate the relative pose
between the color camera and the
depth camera at the last time I
had a color image and the last
time I had a point Cloud, and
then from there we call fit
plane model near click and we
pass in the point Cloud, we pass
in the color image, and we pass
in the relative transform
between the two, which helps us
do that alignment, and then we
get back a point and a plane
model for that pixel in the
image.
After this call we've got a
point and a normal that
we can use to place the cat on
the correct surface in the
environment and we can put it in
the real world.  So I'm going
on    to show a demo of that
now.
So here you'll see that
Mittens is actually looking
pretty good.  He can move around
the world, and every time I tap
, I'm getting that detection,
and you can see that I can make
Mittens sort of interact with
the surface        surfaces and
the geometry of the environment.
(applause)
.
S we'll still get
cooler
We'll still get cooler.  I like
the enthusiasm, though.  It's
sort of building over time.  I
can have Mittens jump on this as
well, and he can jump down.
And if we like, we can also
change  Mittens to Rufus.  All
right.  Let's go back to the
slides.
So we're getting better, but
you'll notice that I didn't have
the cat go behind anything, and
the reason I didn't do that is
because we don't have support in
that demo for occlusion.  What
that means is if I had placed
Mittens behind the podium and
looked at it from kind of the
incorrect angle, I would have
seen through the podium and
Mittens wouldn't have rendered
realistically.  So what can we
do along the way to maybe do
more about understanding our
scene and our geometry and our
environment to make Mittens look
even better and even more
realistic?  Well, Tango can
create rough 3D reconstructions
of the world environment, and it
provides developers with these
meshes in realtime, which is
really kind of crazy when you
think about it.  And perhaps we
can use these meshes to help a
little bit with our occlusion
problem.  So now instead of
using a single point to
determine how to render the cat
and to have Mittens jump from
the table to the chair to the
floor, we can use like the full
3D structure of the environment
and aggregate many points over
time.  So under the hood what
Tango is meshing, it's actually
taking many, many different
viewpoints, doing sort of that
same transform I talked about to
get the point Cloud into the
world frame and binning them
over time and creating a
representation of this surface
that gets better actually the
more that you look at a surface
because you get more points of
data and a better accurate of
the surface.
This process is pretty complex
but it is again abstracted for
us by the SDK, and we've got a
meshing library that you can use
in C plus plus or we've hacked
it up              hooked it
directly up to Unity that gives
you the mesh inside the game
engine in realtime and makes it
really easy to use it in our
depth buffer as we render.  So
to see this, we'll check out
another demo
.  All right.  So we'll put
Mittens over here for now
now.  So you can see that as I
move around the podium, I'm
starting to build up a rough
mesh of it.  That's probably
good enough for now.  We'll put
Mittens sort of in the
background.  And as I move, you
can see he becomes occluded.  We
think that this is a really
powerful thing for building AR
applications.  We can sort of
bring him out.
(applause)
.
One thing that you'll
notice is that the mesh isn't
perfect, so we'll play some
tricks, like we actually alpha
blend on the edge of Mittens as
he goes behind and here we've
even show you his silhouette
when he's behind the podium to
give you a sense that he's still
there.  I'm going to show
another version right now that
does a similar thing but it's
not going to show the silhouette
s, so Mittens will be fully
occlude and had you'll get to
see how that looks as well.
So probably good enough.  Now
we'll put Mittens behind again
and you can see as I go, you
know, he kind of pops out over
time
and there's Alpha blending on
the edges we're use to go sort
of make him fade in and out.  So
it's not perfect, but it does
give the illusion of a more real
experience.  All right.  Let's
go back to the slides.
At this point we've created a
pretty compelling augmented
reality application, I would say
.  We've taken Mittens, we've
placed him in the world, he can
walk on surfaces, he can jump on
chairs, and now he can actually
be occluded by objects in the
scene.  So you've
got a lot of the components of
making a compelling augment
augmented reality
experience right there in front
of you.  But it can be a lot
better and one thing I'll say,
have you guys noticed anything
weird about this picture up here
?
Does something look fake to you
maybe?  Yeah?  People are --
audience participation?  The
Lamborghini is fake.  The front
one is actually not a real car
and the reason that this looks
so good is that we're doing a
lot in terms lighting and
reflection
, we've placed it exactly where
we want and done very detailed
composite ing of it.  This is
the holy grail of AR, and this
slide is really just to say that
this is a journey and we're
moving along this path, moving
towards things awe hope someday
can look like this, but this is
not itionz the expectation to
have today -- but this is not I
guess the expectation to have
today for where we are.  As an
application developer, it's
important to remember that
that, and in building
something you want to ask
yourself, is it appropriate for
the technology I have at hand?
Everything from the art assets
that you use to the game play
that you design can help to set
exchtionz for
expectations for your users, and
you can still make really
compelling experience
s that use maybe a subset of the
technology as well.  So you
could put a solar system in
space, you could have your
catwalk on planes but not be
occluded, or you could have, you
know, objects and games that
take advantage of the scene
geometry, but all of them are
compelling in their own right
right, and with a little
bit of creativity, you can
actually make experiences that
feel really good to people even
if you're not leveraging the
full capabilities of AR and even
if you don't get to the holy
grail of Lamborghini rendering.
To illustrate this, I guess
I'll provide two examples of
augmented reality applications
that I really like that don't
even use depth.  So the first
one I've been alluding to for a
while.  This was done by some of
our friends at San Francisco
State University and it allows
you to explore the solar system
by placing planets in a line in
your room, and I'll show a demo
of that now.
So here I'm going to tap to
place the sun, and now I'm going
to walk and I guess it
recommends I go further than
this, but this is about as far
as I get.  And I will tap to
place Neptune.  So now as I walk
back towards the sun rgs I can
sun, I can see the
scale of the planets relative
to each other, and it's
actually correct, and I can
zoom in to each one of the
planets, and if I want, I can
start to see how orbits work.
And as an educational tool, this
is spectacular.  And from an
augmented reality perspective,
it's actually remarkably simple.
I mean, this is the floating
cat that we all laughed at
before, but for the appropriate
application, it's actually quite
compelling
.  All right.  We'll go back to
the slides for a second.  The
second application I want to
talk about is a game from our
friends at Trixi Studios, and
it's called phan     phanaguys.
How many of you actually went
to our after-hours event and got
to play Phantaguys?  Way too
few of you.  So Phanta
Phantaguys is a game and the
premise is that aliens have
invaded your world and you need
to zap them before they take
over the world, and it's not
good for us at the end.  But
anyway, there are a bunch of
design considerations that went
into this game that I really
like, so the characters are
actually semi transparent, they
feel like they're coming out of
the wall, and they're very
clever about using the position
of the device and making
assumptions about free pace
space to interact with the
world even though they don't
know where surfaces are.  I will
show a brief demo of this,
actually.  I'm going to go to
bonus content.  We'll do a giant
worm thing.  All right.  So you
can tell they're already
setting the mood with the music
that they have for this, and
what happens is as I start, the
devices records my position in
space.  Can we turn down the
lights?  Awesome.  So we'll get
a brief text message that says
something like the aliens will
get you, or clear the area.  So
as I move, you'll see kind of
something strange happens.
(Buzzing, beeping)
.
(Boom) so here we've
ripped a hole in the actual
floor and we can see -- whoa.
(Various game noises)
all right.  We're safe.  So if
we switch back to the slides
real quick.
I think it's pretty cool.  All
right.  So everything that you
saw there
used only motion tracking.
There was no decht,        depth
, there was no occlusion.  It's
kind of shocking.  I'm actually
impressed with how well they
pulled it off.  But they're
playing tricks.  They're making
some assumptions and building
game play that just works for
the environment.  So really this
is to say that, you know, there
are ways in game play to make
things feel real and immersive
even with our most basic API,
and as you start to move down
the road, it gets just better.
With all that said, I've said a
lot of managing expectations
type stuff, but we're continuing
to improve, we're always
working on new things, and, in
fact, we're rolling out some
drift correction code into our S
D   SDK's over the next couple
months.  So Wim talked about
this before, but another problem
that you have with augmented
reality is that when I place the
cats in the world, actual let's
switch back to the demo just
real quick.  I think it's easy
to show.
So you can see that the cat is
on a surface, it's relatively
robust to when I move the device
around because our tracking is
relatively good, but if I'm
really mean, okay, the cat is
gone, right?  It drifted off
into space.  So we can go back
to the slides.  So we've
actually built software that
allows us to correct for that,
so when the cat goes drifting
off into space, we recover very,
very quickly.  It takes about a
second.  But you stop, look at
the world, and the cat shows up
back in the correct place.  This
is really just one of the
improvements that we're working
to roll out and that we're
working to bring to you, our
developer community.  We're
working on things like modeling
the lighting in the room to give
you realistic shadows, things
like improving our meshing and
doing texture ing as well to
give realistic texture ed meshes
inside of Unity that maybe you
could use in other games and
maybe even import them into
different game worlds.  We're
just taking steps along this
journey to getting to that
Lamborghini, to getting to
really, really good and
immersive and solid augmented
reality, but we don't have to
wait.  We can already do a lot
right now and build compelling
experiences today      today.  I
also want to talk a little bit
about the trade-offs that you
make as you start to use more
and more of this technology.  So
heat is your enemy on a mobile
device.  If any of you have used
a mobile phone before, you know
it gets hot.  It's hot in your
pocket.  You're using Google
Maps and it's just like burning
up, and it is a very real
trade-off.  So we've worked hard
to optimize our algorithms, to
optimize our computer vision
software and to make it run as
quickly and efficiently as
possible, but more capabilities
you use, the more CPU and
compute you use as well.  So if
you can make an experience work
with motion tracking, then you
have a lot more that you can
throw at your game.  But if you
go all the way to full meshing,
maybe you should be using some
low poly models.  It's just
important to be aware of the
trade-offs that you make when
you think about the applications
that you could build.
If I could sum up my talk with
one cheesy statement, I would
do it with creativity is king.
When you're developing for a
newspaper platform, you know,
there are limitations -- when
you're developing for a new
platform, there are limitations
and we're super-fortunate to
partner with people who can be
creative and who have worked
around the different
capabilities and technologies of
the device as well as their
limitations, and we're really
looking forward to seeing what
kind of creative applications
can be enable ed, but
enabled by what is super
-powerful technology over the
coming months.  There's a bunch
that you should check out at our
sandbox to get a picture of
what developers are up to.  If
you haven't done that, I really
encourage it, and there are a
couple of things awe've done
that are really exciting at the
platform, too, looking forward.
So first, we believe that
Project Tango technology should
become ubiquitous, all devices
should have the ability to
understand where they are in
space and to understand the
geometry of their environments,
and one thing that we've done is
we've worked closely with our
friends at the Android team to
start moving some of Tango's API
's into core Android.  So in
Android N you can actually ask
for the 6 degree of freedom pose
of the device through Android
APIs and Android N also supports
depth sensors.  Over time we
hope to expose more of Tango's
capabilities in this way and
we're at the beginning of a
very, very exciting journey on
the consumer front.  So we have
announced a
partnership with Lenovo where
we'll be shipping Project Tango
Smartphones later this summer.
This is huge.  This says a big
deal.  This has been a three-
year journey for us to take this
technology from the prototype
stage all the way to something
that you can actually hold in
your hands, and a lot of the
applications we're showing here
start to show the power of these
devices for consumers.  So now
is really the time to get on
board, like the train is sort of
like leaving the proverbial
station, and I'm really excited
to see what we can build
together         together.  It's
a great time to get your foot
in the door if you haven't been
thinking about augmented reality
applications, I encourage you
to do so, expit also a unique
opportunity to partner with
Google.  So we're always looking
for interesting ideas.  We like
to feature or partners with
things like talks, and on
occasion we even put out like RF
P's for unique augmented reality
content.  This all happens
because it's a new and budding
eke system, it's
budding ecosystem,
it's an exciting time to take
the first step in this journey
together.  With that, I'm ending
my talk.  Hopefully this gave
you an idea of the kind of
applications that are possible
with Project Tango as well as
some of the considerations that
you need to be aware of when
you're building augmented
reality content.  I think it's a
really exciting time.  I'm
really happy to be here.  I feel
fortunate to be on the team.
Thank you guys so much for your
time this morning, and I hope
you enjoy the rest of I/O.
Thank you very much.
(applause).
10:38 a.m.)
>>
May 20, 2016.
Live coding:  Make a
virtual reality game.
.
..
>> SHANEE NISHRY: Hi,
everyone, my name is Shanee
Nishry, I am a software engineer
.  I hope you're all as excited
as I am about the Daydream
announcement two days ago and I
hope many of you developers out
here and online are eager to
join us and develop for Daydream
.  So I figured a lot of you
developers might come from a
more traditional graphics
development and I thought it
would be really fun to teach how
to develop for Daydream by
making a game.  So this is what
we are going to do today.  We
are going to learn some very
basic Unity3D skills.  We'll add
the Google VR SDK, some gay
play and have fun and play.
Now, if you have Unity on your
laptop, feel free to join me and
develop with me.  You can get
the SDK on the link above and
the games asset on the link
underneath.  If you are online
and you don't have Unity, get it
off Unity3D.com.  I'm just
going on leave this slide
to leave this
slide for a moment.
I'm going to keep going.  So
this is what we are going to do
today.  Let's meet our gaism the
we are going
game.  We are going to
make a very simple defend the
castle game.  This is also
online right now on Git hub in
our samples folder.  There are
going to be three bridges
connecting the island from one
side to the other.  We'll have
Androids made of Cardboard
follow a path, on bridges, and
onto a castle, trying toin Vader
T we'll be adding rendering
later.  We'll be adding binaural
audio.  Now, audio is really
important for completely
immersive experience.  3D
auditory cues will tell you when
a canon is being shot over your
head and where to look.
Finally, we'll add some
interaction using the input
and this will work both for the
old Cardboard and for the
controller on day dreevment oh,
and this.  How many of you have
made games?  Put up your hands
if you're a game developer.  Did
you ever run into are your CPU
went too hard and you need to do
take a break until you can keep
working
, or maybe you're like me and
you just put your phone into the
fridge for it to cool down?
We'll look into some
optimisation tips so you can get
a 6PS.  These will be assets in
the game, as eghts we've made
before.  We have the cann
cannon and the castle and some I
took from the Cardboard design
lab, which is also online.  This
is how we are going to make
this     this.  To make the game
, I have usmsed Unity and
used Unity and
blender but you can use any tool
on the market and whatever you
like, even if you have your own
engine, there is a C plus plus
which will be in more detail a a
talk later.  A quick overview
into Unity if you've never used
it before I'll go over it
briefly.  This is how a Unity
game editor looks like.  At the
center we just have our scene,
we can move it and look around
using a virtual camera.  We can
also use drag and drop engines
around.  On the left is the
objects that we have inside the
scene.  The on the right is the
inspector.  You can look at any
object and see what it is made
of   of.  Every object is made
of several components.  For
example, here on the top is the
transform component
saying what's our position and
scale.  At the bottom is the
project assets.  That's all of
the scripts, models and textures
inside our project.  Now, a
very quick word about Blender.
As a game developer for many
years, I've found that having
some 3D editing skill really
empowers you because it means
you can make your own models and
experiment and make your own
game if you want.  However, this
is how Blender looks like.
Now, Blender is an Open Source
project which is free for
everyone to use, which is why I
picked it, and this is how it
looks, and it can be a bit
intimidate ing.  I've learnld
how to use it through this site,
but I'm pretty sure there are
many other websites out there.
Okay.  Let's get to work very
quick and will see how far we
can go
quick and will see
how far we can go.  I'll just
open Unity, and if you have it,
if you've downloaded the project
, feel free to do so.  So just
to show you the basics, really.
This is how a new project looks
like.  I have the scene, I can
press alt and look around or
with the mouse wheel button and
I can go to the game object menu
at the top and maybe add a
plane to use as my ground, now
it's inside the scene.  I have
beginning camera, the main
camera which I can move around.
On the bottom right you can see
that the camera preview and
what it will see.  Now, if I add
just a cube, I'm starting very
basic and we'll go on in a bit
bit.  So now I have a cube in
the scene and I can press plail
here at the top and basically
-- and I can press play here at
the top and basically what we
see is what we get.  However,
there are some problems here,
the biggest of we don't have
stereoscopic rendering.  Luckily
it is really simple to get it
with our SDK.  Now, I have
downloaded
the package for importing the
Google VR SD      VR SDK before,
and this is simply a Unity
package.  I can double click on
it and it will load all the
relevant as etsz         assets
into our project.  Now, next I'm
just going to delete the main
camera because we no longer need
it.  We want to have
stereoscopic view.  So I'm
delete ing that.  And as you may
see here down at the project
assets we have the Google VR
folder now.  So going to it, and
I'll employ to prefabs, and
then I will drag the Google VR
main into the scene and place it
just here at the back.  Now,
basically a collection of game
objects already set up with
components is a prefab.  In this
case this is what we need to do
stereoscopic rendering.  I can
press play and now we have all
we need for VR.  If I press alt,
I can simulate head movement,
use my mouse and look around.
The stereoscopic camera
basically works if I open up it
on the left in the arrow key, it
has a head and a stereo, head
also has a camera which is a
template camera for two
different cameras.  One camera
for HI simulate ing the distance
between our two eyes -- for
each eye, simulate ing the
distance between our two eyes.
This is how we do the illusion
of depth and depth sensation so
we know how far someone on the
Cloud is from me or I am from
you.  Okay.  Now let's open up a
project I have prepared
beforehand so we can get started
because if I start make ing the
entire scene from scratch, it's
going on take quite
to take quite a while.
So this is the very basic scene.
I can move inside by zooming
in using the scroll wheel or the
touch pad and I can look around
.  Let's see what we are going
to do.  So we have our castle
made of cardboard and on the
other side of the island we have
the little Android statue
signifying where the in
invaiding Androids will come
from.  Here on top of the castle
we also have our cannon that
we'll be using to fire at the
Androids.  And again, all the
assets here including the scenes
are already ready for you to
download off GitHub.  If I press
play, I've already prepared the
camera on top of one of the
towers, so I can look around and
see where the Androids come
from.  However, nothing is
happening at the moment, so
we'll need to add some game play
.  Let's see how we are going to
add Androids to span from
somewhere in the island.  So I'm
just going to disable a few
scenes on the left.  I'm going
to collect a new game object.
Let's say just an empty one.
And I'm going on call it spawn L
because this is what I'm going
on spawn my Androids from.  So
I'm going on create a new
component and I'll just call it
spawn L because it's simple.
Then I can double click on the
inspector to open and tap and
develop or whatever scape you
want to use.  I'm going to add a
short timer, I'll start it at
maybe one second to begin with
and let's add another one for
respond time.  We'll set it up
to 5 seconds.  Now on the app
date what we should be doing
is decrease our timer so we can
get new Androids into our scene
.  So we'll use time delta time
and then if our timer
is
-- oh, before I can span
Androids, I need to have some
locations I can spawn them from.
So let's add a list of
transformations, correspond
points, and just initialize it
here
.  So now if I look into the
scene, you see that the final
step is it going to update in
just a moment.  There we go.
Now we have the time and her
respond timer, and we'll be able
to
add some points to let the skip
know where to place Androids at
.  We also need to create a path
into the island, so for that
what we can do just to make it
simple again      again, I will
create a new game object that
will be a sphere and I can place
it somewhere inside the scene,
and this signifies a point in
space at the moment.  Sphere
collide er so objects do not
collide with it later on.  Then
I will add way points which I've
prepared beforehand, a list of
what the next point is going to
be.  And then I can duplicate
this, just comment C, comment V,
and I can go into the first
scweer and drag and drop the
sphere from the air     arrow
key into the next.  So I can
have them linked to each other.
Then I have to keep doing it
until they cross over the bridge
and go to the castle, but this
is just a way to start.  So now
that we have some objects and
we'll go and add the initial
point into the spawn points, and
now if the timer is less than
zero, then we'll just Seth the
timer back
set the timer back to the
respond timer, and we'll go to
an Android pool, which I will go
into more detail later, and
I'll create the position that is
my position, I'm going to do a
transform, create, transform
, and I'll use this size of the
elements inside my list.
There we go.  Have I missed a
bracket somewhere?
Good.  Okay.  Now that we have
the two set up and we'll press
play again.  If we go over to
the scene view, we'll see every
few seconds, every five seconds
specifically, we'll have an
Android coming up.  Now, I'm not
going on create the entire path
here because I think that
everything should be done later.
It's not very interesting.  So
I do have an my's path
enemy patz, and if I go to
layer up here at the right and
mark invisible to enable it, we
can see it in here,
and I'll just collapse it, I'll
collapse this one, I'll go to
the spanner and drag and drop
any way points here from the
left and onto the list.  Now
that I press play again, we'll
have Android spawning from virus
spawn points here on the scene
and will go over to the castle.
So the different path.  So we
have basic Androids coming to
the scene.  We can look at them
from the game.  I can also
maximize, say you might be able
to    to see it, but we don't
have any way to interact with
them.  We need some kind of a
way to shoot them off our island
so they don't get to the castle
.  So let's look into our ground
.  Let's look at how we are
going to shoot with the cannon
onto the ground somehow.  So
select egg the terrain
selecting the
train, I'll go to add component
and I'll add a target behavior
and we'll make a quick strip so
we can shoot onto the cannons.
I don't need the star to update
here, so I will make a new
function on   , one click, then
I will use the base event data
from Unity
and then I will appoint an
event data
maybe I will actually name this
.  But before that, I need to
make sure I actual have a Kansas
on inside                  cann
on inside the scene.  I did add
one beforehand, so just make
sure it actually exists.
And now we'll make the can on
shoot -- we'll make the cannon
shoot from the can
non side of the scene onto the
intersection point.
What am I missing here?
One of those brackets.
Oh, sorry about that.  I'm
using the wrong script.  All I'm
going to do is use the
transformation from the cast sp
I'll get to more detail
and I'll get
to more detail on that in a
moment.  Let's see what position
.  That sounds about right.
Okay.  But even now, if I press
onto the terrain, nothing will
happen.  We need to add a few
more interactions here.  The
first thing we need to do is add
a way to receive events from
Unity and from our Google VR SDK
so we know when an object has
actually been clicked anyway.
So I'm going to add an event
system from Unity.  The event
system, all it does is relay the
events between objects, so it
comes with a stand alone input
module which I'm going to remove
wawz      because we're not
going to use it and I'll add a g
aze input module, which will
basically take the orientation
of our camera and transform it
into the events.  At the moment
there is not such element for
the controller, but this will be
coming soon.  So the next thing
I need to do is go to my camera
and say Google VR main, go to
the main camera template, and
we'll add physics castle.  Now
on its own, the event system
will allow you to interact with
UI canvas elements, but if you
want to interact with objects
inside the scene, you need to
add a physics ray caster to
interact with T I'll set the
event mask which basically says
which layers in the scene are
interactable, I'll set it up and
then I will set it again to the
grade.  The grade is the name
it shows for the terrain.  You
can see it here on layer, it is
selected as grade, and that
means that when the gaze input
module is looking into the
camera, finding its views, it's
going on find exactly which
object it is looking on but only
from the layers that you have
enable ed.  So the next thing we
need to do, okay, now we have
everything kind of working and
interactable but we never
actually call our script from
anywhere.  Going tbook our
terrain, I just click on it here
in the editor, what we need to
do, and this is our water, so
click again Otter ain,
on the terrain, is click
an event trigger.  The event
trigger basically says that this
object is listening for the
following events, and I will add
a pointer click event and then
I will select the aim object, I
can just drag and drop it from
here, from the scene on the left
into the missing component, and
then it shows me all the
components that are on this
object and I can select the one
I want.  So I've made a target
behavior.  So I will just select
on click, and when I press play
the next time and I look around
, I will be able to activate the
cannon and we'll be able to
fire onto the Android.  However,
it's actually really difficult
and I will just put it first
game actually, it is actually r
eally difficult to aim this way.
I have no idea what I'm
pointing at.  I'm just doing
this in tandem almost.  So what
I'm going to do is add a
vertical.  So search here in the
project assets and I will find
the Google VR vertical.  What
I'm going to do is drag it down
onto the head and I'll make sure
that its position is reset here
in the inspector, it already is
, so that's good, and the next
time I start my scene
scene, you see there is a little
point in the middle of the
screen which is telling me where
I'm looking at.  Now, if it
looks at an object that is
marked as interactable, it will
grow to signify that the object
can be interacted in some way
and I can shoot there.  However,
once again, we have game play,
we have some minimal
interaction, but the game field
is empty.  I mention
mentioned before in the
presentation that to make a
really good virtual reality
experience, you want to have
sound, so let's look into how we
are going to add some sound in.
So I want to have an epic
sound for the cannon whenever I
shoot at the Androids, so I'm
going to look into my cannonball
object.  The cannonball object
is found every time where I
select to shoot somewhere into
the scene.  The first thing it
will do is I will add in audio
source.  If you have listened to
the binaural audio presentation
earlier, you might be familiar
with it, but this is our Google
VR implementation of 3D binaural
audio, and you
can use it just like this.  Now
it's on the object.  I'm going
to select a specific sound.  The
cannonball fire sound.  I've
also prepared the cannonball
behavior which is what controls
the flight of the cannon and
then the explosion at the end,
and it has another element here
for the impact audio.  So just
going here and I will select the
canon impact here on the left,
and if you look quickly on the
cannonball behavior, will see on
impact here at the bottom
bottom, and what it does is
select the variable which I have
just filled in and it will play
it once our cannonball is just
about to hit the ground
.  If you're following on the
YouTube video later, you can
easily find it all.  Now here
are additional settings for the
sounds.  In this case I want it
to be an epic explosion, so I'm
just going to put the game in
and hope it will all work well
on these speakers here, but you
also have settings for direct
activity, which is how the sound
is going to distribute and
spread out in space.  If I set
this here, it will show how the
sun will spread.  If I use
larger on the font, it will
spread more towards the back.
If I use the sharpness, it will
make it more sharp, as you would
expect, so give it more for
direction.  For the cannonball I
will use sound that spreads in
everywhere at the same time.
You can also enable occlusion
for the sound to bounce off
elements into the scene, from
the scene, but I'm going on skip
that at the moment.  Now, I
kind of want to press play and
just see how the sound is
working, but it will not work.
There's one more step we need to
do.  If I go edit here on the
top and to project settings and
go to audio, we need to set the
specialized plug in here on the
right from none to Google VR
specialized.  And once again,
all these instructions will be
in the GitHub read me file.
Now, the next time I press play,
when I fire at Androids, and I
will maximize this again, here
is one, it's coming, there we go
, we'll have some 3D audio.
Now, if you're with speakers on
a device or even on the computer
, you will find out that when
you look in different directions
, the stereo sound will come as
you would expect it to come from
.  I also want to add some
sounds to the Androids, but I'm
going to here have a lot to
cover, so I have all this
prepared beforehand, I'll look
for Android and search it in the
project and find the Android
prefab and I'm going to add
another Google VR audio source
component.  Now, I'm not going
to set any sound in here.  I'm
going to disable the player,
this is because I've already set
some sounds here in different
lists and if we go into the
script itself, you will notice
there are multiple lis of audio
clips -- multiple lists of audio
clips, and when we enable the
Android, it will play the charge
sound, and when it's going to
be exploded away by the cannon,
it will play an impact sound,
just as an example.  Now, when I
press play, every time an
Android responds, it will have
some kind of a charge, and when
I shoot towards it and hit it,
it will have an oh-oh sound and
fly away.  You'll probably hear
it better on a device.  You can
get the APK from the GitHub,
it's online right now.  So this
is the Google VR interaction,
the stereoscopic rendering and
the audio.  A few quick more
words about the interaction.
When you're pointing at an
element, let's do it as an
example, I'm going to maximize
it, it's quite smart actually.
In VR you really need to be able
to converge exactly where
you're looking at and it tends
to take the depth of the element
that you are pointing at.  So
if we are pointing at the
terrain here, it's
not only spreading out to show
that the terrain is
interactable, but it's actually
casting its position onto the
depth of the terrain itself.
However, in this case, I've not
set trees to be occlude ers
inside the event as well as the
tower, which means that the
theoretical is probably render
rendering in front of
them but still being visible,
which can make some issues with
convergence, especially if I
look down here onto the terrain
but also onto the tower.  So
what you want to do in these
cases is go to your main camera
and add some more elements into
the event down here.  For
example f we add the default,
you'll notice that whenever we
are looking onto a tower or a
tree, it will no longer
glow and it will be cast
properly.  Now, I have just
about
15 minutes, and this is a very
basic game, but I
really want to talk about
performance here.  When I was
making this demo, I had about
two and a half weeks to do it,
and I was trying to do some
really fancy stuff.  However,
doing work and work ng a game
demo -- and working in a game
demo at the same time actually
turned out to be pretty
difficult and after the game was
finished, it maybe ran at like
45 per second, which is not
great.  Now it's running at 60 S
PS on the device at full
resolution.  But this gave me
even more firsthand experience
to give you some performance
tips, so let's look into them.
If you look into the Google VR,
we will notice that we have VR
mode enable ed, which is what we
want to do, but we also have
distortion correction.  If we
press play and we look into the
distortion, you can set it to
none, which means it's not going
to if I can the distortion.
The distortion has been
distortion caused by the lenses
when you're looking through them
onto the skin.  You want to use
distortion correction.
However, there are several ways
to do so.  If you have watched
the vertex distortion correction
presentation, I'm not sure if
it was before mine or after, but
it mentions a way to do
correction
without processing.  The way we
do it here is by doing it on a
post process, which means we'll
need to draw every pixel again
with the correction.  The vertex
correction happens when you are
drawght objects themselves onto
the screen, and it will distort
them to fit and look how they
should do so you don't need to
use additional pixel rendering
time and waste more of your GPU
bandwidth because that tends to
be one of the more expensive
things, so if I'm not using the
vertex base correction rs I'll
use either native or Unity n
this case I'm using Unity, and
you can play with the stereo
screen scale.  That changes the
virtual display that we are
drawing to.  When we are drawing
our scene, game or application,
we're actually drawing it into
an offskin backfill which is the
larger size of our real scene
.  We're doing it so we can
remove any artifacts or
distortion and not lose any
details.  So we are fixing the
pixel error by drawing on high
resolution.  But sometimes
depending on the device you'll
find that the generate ed
resolution is too high and you
might want to change it from one
to maybe 0.9
or 0.8.  I will leave it at 1
here because it's working quite
well.  The other thing you can
do is go into your edit menu and
go into project
and we'll look into quality
here.  So I would like to make a
new quality level, I call it
Google VR or GVR for short and I
set Android to be the
defaulted, use it by default.
Now, depending on your scene, if
you're using a lot of lighting,
I would suggest to bake all
your lighting into a texture.
I'm not going to go over how to
do it now.  There's enough
information on it online.  It
takes into account, and
depending on your scene, you
might even be able to move to
vertex lighting, but that's in a
different menu, so go to it
later.  If you are not using
soft particles or any reflection
s, you might want to disable
this.  I do suggest keeping
multisample ing at least at two.
When you're looking into the
screen through the lenses and
you don't have multisample ing
on, then you will see all the
area scene and jagged edges and
that's not a pretty experience
on your eyes to see all these
jagged edges.  So try to make
sure that your game or
application is performing well
enough to enable listening at
least 2X because
otherwise it's just not going
to look as great unless you're
render egg at much higher
resolution.  Now, as I mentioned
, if you can, play with your
shadows, play with your lights,
try to bake your shad dose if
you can and then if you can, you
can disable your realtime
shadows, and another thing you
can do is change the shadow
cascades instead.  Now, if we go
into -- oh, and 145D dough
cascades -- oh   oh, and shadow
cascades is multiple shadow maps
to have different qualities
between shadows near the camera
or further away because the
shadows near the camera are
higher quality because the
player can see all of the
artifacts happening.  Now,
another thing we can do is go
here into player.  You have to
set your default orientation to
landscape left to work with the
viewer.  Another thing you might
be able to do to gain more
performance and sound quality
over mobile is disable the 3D
display buffer.  The reason for
it is because some phones do not
actually have 32 bit support
support.  So on some
Galaxy phones, for example, you
will get more shadow artifacts
without it because of the
emulation layer, and then if
you're using only 16 bits,
you're getting less bandwidth
usage, which means you're gect
less performance and less hit
has been generated on the
hardware itself.  If you go to
auto setting, as I mentioned
earlier, you can change to
vertex lighting, or you can keep
it at forward if you have good
enough performance, depending on
how you have made your scene
and your game.  I do very much
recommend enabling multisyllabic
rendering because that will
take a big chunk of your C   CPU
usage to another thread.
Multiit threadI can and you will
not be as CPU later for hitting
up one code, using up all the
bandwidth there
.  You should uses static and
dynamic bachg.  What that does
-- batching
batching.  What does
does is reduce your dropped
calls.  Say I go to the game and
I press on the stats over here,
you can see that I have about
16 drop cores inside the scene
approximate 162 vertices.  If I
press play, I will have just
about double that amount because
Unity is going to be able to
opt mieps the sound level.  The
reason for it is because we are
drawing the scene twice, so it's
doing double the work, and you
need to make sure that you are
not having too many verdict sees
in the scene or too many
triangles.  Another thing that I
have noticed with Unity, and
you might be familiar with it,
especially if you have worked
with C++, is that it doesn't
really like instantiate ing
objects, that means a lot of
memorial locations, and for that
I have made a specific memory
pool.  So if you look at the
memory pull      pool in here,
you'll see it has two scapes,
one for the cannonballs and one
for the Androids.  As I press
play, as this object has been
initialize ed, it's creating all
these unused cannonballs and
aims at the Androids which are
slowly being used.  When I shoot
a scan on ball, let's say over
here (Explosion sound), you see
one cannonball has been used at
the top and in a few seconds it
will be disable ed and ready to
be used again.  This is to avoid
heavy memorial locations which
can be very expensive at run
time.  So the way I make a scape
like that is by creating a
single tone and then having a
couple of static functions, one
to create an element and one to
destroy.  On the initialization
of the script, it's going on
make sure if there is no single
tone, to set its own, and then
it will create however many
instances of the object that I
set it to do.  In this case I've
put it on the code, you should
put     put it as a variable
instead.  So I've managed to
finish a little bit ahead of
time, which never happened when
I tried to do before.  So if you
have any questions, this is a
good time for it   it.
(applause)
.
(The
(The session concluded at 11:38
a.m.)
VR18-distortion correction use
ing
vertex
Kerrer
>> Hello, everyone. I'm
Nathan Marks for the Daydream
I am here to talk to you about
enhance ing applicationswebsites
with BV         VR views.  Now,
Daydream is amaze ing and heard
a lot about it, but today I'm
going to talk to you a different
VR platform from Google called
Cardboard. alive and well.
In part because it has some
really property ies.  Cardboard
still is the world's most  and
most widely distributed VR
platform.  It's good at byte
size experiences.  It's you can
drop into and drop out of
really, really  ly.  It also
works on Android.  It is brandd
in a  campaign or give away.
And especially nature of the
content, the fact that you're
not lockd for a long time with
cardboard makes us think of
applications.  That's what I
want to talk to you   The heart
of Cardboard is this idea of VR
for   And when we say that, we
mean not just for VR for use er,
but actually for every
developer and hopefully every
business.  Google is investing
in VR because we it is
transformative technology.
We're also thinking ways to
apply that technology outside of
the most obvious  of games and
media into the real world, into
businesses that most of us run
and support.  With that, would
like to talk to you about a
specific insight, a opportunity
we will talk about.   Imagine
you have a travel website.  Now
travel is a huge of internet
search and commerce.  People
spend amounts of time and money
when they try to  vacations.
When it's an app or website, we
do the with the tools available.
We will talk about MACHU ICH
We have text and cops that try
charts and graphs.  But if
you're traveling to chew  , you
would like to know what it is
like to be the ruins.  You feel
you're immersed in that space,
If you plan the trip, you say
that's so amaze ing. might be
more likely to travel there.
And this idea of  immerse ive
media into more traditional
websites and ,
maybe you're a home , your
whole business is yet to sell
been built yet.  And some people
are going to come your and was
they're going to be excited
about your home, they're going
to walk out the door because
they have  time buying a house
if they can't look around  and
walk to the living room.  Well,
embeddable media can let you do
that.  If you're in retail
retail, you want someone to
design a room or look  room, you
can do that with immerse ive
media. work in news and you want
to power to bring people into
story ies and really remarkable
ways, immerse ive media can that
as well.  Of course, education
is another   You take your
students and teach them world,
take them to places they can
never go that are  or millions
of miles away.  This is all
possible.  we know that even
though there's this great
potential, and most developers
don't have a large team of VR
on stand by just waiting for
this stuff to halfapp is
expensive, but we want to make
it .  That's why I want to talk
to you about a release called V,
Mr. Views.               VR
views.  It's much easier to R
views than it is just to talk
about them.  So, anyone has a
Smartphone, I suspect a few of
you  crazy things called
smartfons, there's a short URL
will take you to a live version
of this demo. it out.  I will
leave the URL up for another
second. pretty freakin' cool and
bonus points if you brought a
or VR of your choice.   Starting
point is an embedded window.
We know that most  not going to
start use ers in VR.  You will
start D.  You want to bring the
window ready -- you want to it
to use ers even before they
entered VR.  We know that of
course, not everyone has a Card
board with them all time.  If
you build this technology and
integrate it the site, you want
it to work in VR and outside of
VR. cool thing with the embedded
magic window on mobile when
move your phone around, the
phone responds and it's live
through the magic window into
this other wording. you have a
couple of choices.  There's a
full button on the lower right.
If you press that, you magic
window, but in full screen.
It's the most you can get
without Card board.  Now, of
course, best option is the VR
option.  If you press that,
stereoscopic real time viewing
designed to be with all our
cardboard viewers.  VR is the
most immerse ive if you have
stereo 360 content.  We will
show you to capture stereo 360
content in just a minute.   It
is great to talk about what it
can do.  You say how I get this
into my application.  I am
really you that everywhere you
want to be, VR views already .
We have web GL based
implementation that works on top
and mobile browse ers.  We
haveinate ive Android  through
our Google SDRK  .  So roadless
of you have an app or a website
whether desk top or  you can use
this technology, use the same
content integrate it with a
minimum of effort.  1 of the
hard  with VR views is actually
compatibility.  Right?  When
talk about browse ers alone,
there's lots of different   We
support all of the leading
browse ers across all major
operate ing systems as long as
you have a relate ively version
of the browser.  I am sorry.  IE
6 not   Otherwise, we're pretty
good.  On Android, wesupport
from everything on Kit Kat on up
and everything IOS 5.0 and up.
Really wide range.  Majority of
use ers want to reach, we have
didn't hard work to do the
compatnot just the compate
ibility.  Also the work to make
sure the decisions work and it
is and response ive, which is
super important especially in .
Inlet aggression are super
simple.  If you want to  view
into your website, it is
basically like atube video.  The
most important field is that
field where you can reference
either scripts that we  and
hosted on Google Cloud storage
or scripts that host yourself.
It is sail the web version all
up in   Super simple.  The get
hub blink is at the  page.  Then
you tell us where to find the
360 degree and there you go.  We
do recommend if you're trying
out for the first time use ing
our scripts that we host great.
But you'll run into things like
cross site core .  You will
have to think about things like
browser ibility in way couple of
cases.  It is much easier.
highly recommend do you that in
any production    On Android, it
is also super simple.ure will
add your  layout XML file.  In
code, you find that layout. case
of an image, you create the map
factory, tell it file to open
and then you just need to get
the options the VR view.  In
this case the VR Panorama view.
whether it is stereo or mono
image and hand it  widget.  Just
that simple.  In IOS, very
similarly.  All to do is
allocate as new VR view, tell it
what to load and add the VR
view as a sub-view to whatever
container it is.  I try very
hard to make sure this is simple
, but natural for the platform
you're develop for.  In all of
these slides, we have Github
link  again at the end of the
talk.   So one of the questions
we get is okay, great.  VR is
awe and it seems really easy to
integrate.  But howget the
content.  Capture ing in 360 is
relate ively new. is extremely
affordable options today.
Before I talk specific capture,
I want to get laments
terminology, is different
between
inside out capture and inside
out  The capture is taken from a
single point looking  and just
like when you're in VR or Card
board, it is  in a point look
looking out into the
wonder.  It      It is
configuration, you but you
really want to be use ing out
capture, not outside in capture.
You want them out rather than
inside in.  In retail, something
like room for home decorate
ing, that's inside out.  You're
in the room looking at the
drains and the like shopping for
shoes is more outside in where
want to look at shoe, rotate in
your hand and you're ing around
the object rather than looking
from the inside   So, one of the
cheapest because it's free and
awesome is to       to capture
stereo 360 is use our cardboard
camera app Android.  It is super
easy to use and one of the best
way capture 360 stereo imagery.
There's a gown load
download link short URL.  If you
want to use the Cardboard
camera  you need a conversion T.
packs the left eye and right
data together in a way you need
to unpack in order to in VR view
.  So we have a really simple
website we put that let's you
drag and drop an image from card
and will automatically format
it for what V view can take.
Super simple.  Use the app.  Use
the con  and you're ready to go
for VR view.
Another great affordable is
the 360 options.  The it is
monoscopic.  So, in a way that
card  supports stereo 360, Rico
supports mono360, support
capture ing video and still
photography.  Now, course we
talked about real world context,
but -- sorry.  er is not
limited to the real world.  CG
is a source.  They want to show
people what the home will look
You are probably going to be
capture ing your 360 views
renders of your architectural
drawings and there's a of great
plug ins from game engines like
on real engine unit to more
traditional offline like Rend
erman and Mea. is the same form
that VR view supports.   So
let's talk a little bit about
the specifics of the for  that
work in VR view.  So, we support
-- it was base format a mono360
piano.  It looks like that.
People call it a late long
image.  It is a very serious
format  We also support its
stereo cousin which you will is
ADS which is really just two
pianos.  One for each stacked on
top of each other.  A stereo
image looks very like a mono im
age.  We also support in the
first both images and videos.
So, 360 stills, 360 videos  of
course,
mono and stereo on both of
them.  If you a Mono 360 image,
you want your ratio to be 1021.
good
baseline for mono 360N. stereo,
it's a square you're stacking
two of the one image on top of
by one image.  For performance
and compatibility the maximum
dimensions are 496 by 4096.  We
support JPEG and GMP.  This s
especially for anything that
very traffic.  On the video side
of things, we strong recommend
you stick to MP4, H264 with a 6
by 9 interesting thing on video
is that this device for video is
much more varied especially on
mobile it is for imagery.  It is
on any modern phone 4096 .  You
will find with video is that
some phones cap out 10 ADP.  And
others will decode at 4K.  If
you want one works everywhere
uses a mono10 ADP 699 for your .
If you want to target hire ing
devices and you would now have
four versions that it works and
then a higher Fidelity ideally
216 DP deliver the devices that
you know support it.   One last
walk with video is there's a
wide variety of  that work.
They're always divisible by
16.   So, I think that's a
really great overview of how all
of stuff works.  We talked
about the applications whether a
home buildinger or a journalist
or in retail.  And got a lot of
great resources if you want to
learn more. have a getting
started guide on developers.
google.com/VR. only have a few
hours left, but I highly
encourage check out one of the
kiosks.  If they're not able to
get it in time for today's IO,
they'll be available online
help you understand the base ics
of getting in  create ing an
app and create ing a website and
make it with embeddable VR
media.  I want to leave plenty
of for Q&A if you have any
questions or thoughts.  Please
up. >> I am Ben. Two quick
questions.  One is will we see
Cardboard camera for IOS and two
is -- well not a question much.
There's an issue with VR view
in IOS right now 9.0 Chrome of
the browser is always there when
you're Cardboard view.  And one
more question.  Will Daydream
be able to access these views?
>> Nathan: Number 1. No
additional product announcement
right now.  Number 2, thank you
for the bug   If you haven't
fileed it on Github, that's how
we all of these things.  If
anyone uses things and has , we
just launched this a couple of
months ago.  File , file tickets
.  We will get them addressed as
quicklypossible.  I'm sorry.  I
forgot your third.  Oh, yeah.
the question is:  Will Daydream
devices be able to  views?
Basically the short is very
focused on cardboard.  Daydream
them like a card board in the
sense you put a phone it and
look through it, but I don't
want to give that VR view will
make your website or
automatically Daydream ready.
One of the things I think is
really cool about VR view is
they don't to you build a VR app
from the ground up.  You can
use app with traditional 2D X
and drop it into immerse ive if
you want.  We call it self-
contained view VRthey can stay
in VR to access all the your VR
content and that's a fundamental
change.  It's of the lead from
snackable VR to long form VR.
It is designed to solve for.
>> Hi. Thanks for that. That
any plans on fallback for
devices alterd in Kit Kat? >>
Nathan:  So, not currently.  The
question is about  for older
devices in Kit Kat?  Right now,
May 20, 2016.
Improve user
acquisition campaigns with
analytics.
.
..
>> So like one big
launch this week wasn't enough.
So I'll be flying solo, so
you'll have to bear with me.
We're going to be talking about
Firebase Analytics and we'll be
talking about it in the context
of growth.  So actually growing
our user base, trying to get
more users into your app and
then keeping them there.  And
I'm going to talk about Firebase
Analytics in three sections.
First I'll give a quick overview
of Firebase Analytics,
hopefully some of you guys can
stop by our sandbox or attend
some of the other sessions, so
it might not be new, but I'll go
ahead and give a quick recap.
Then I will be talking about
using Analytics to actual track
your paid acquisition campaigns,
so looking at advertising and
tracking advertising with
Firebase Analytics.  And then
finally we're going to touch on
organic growth, so actual a
couple of tools that you can use
Firebase, use with Firebase,
and track using Firebase
Analytics, since we know that as
a marketer, advertising is only
one of the tools that you're
using.  And when we're actually
going through this, I'll be
using a hypothetical marketer
named Mike.  Now, let's start
with the reason why so many of
us are here.  We've got
consumers spending a lot of time
in mobile apps when they're on
their phones.  So between Google
Play and the app store, we've
got millions          Mill
millions of apps that are
generate ing north of $50
billion annually.  So that is a
lot of value coming from a lot
of users.  How do we actually
reach those users?  How do we
present opportunities for those
users to discover our apps?
Wern that on                We
know that on average, a use ser
unlocking their phone 150 times
a day.  They're usually doing
specific tasks are like calling
an Uber or looking for a nearby
coffee shop, looking for a game
to download when they're waiting
for the bus.  I like to think
of these as 150 opportunities
for us as marketers, different
chances we can get in front of
our users and show them content
that they could be interested in
.  But even though we have these
150 opportunities a day, the
ecosystem has created a lot of
challenges for us as marketers,
so a couple quick highlights.
First, it can be hard to actual
find the right user in your app,
so figuring out who that target
audience should be and making
sure it's a relevant market,
making sure you're finding them
on the correct devices, at the
right time, eghts accidents
thaidz                 , that's
always an issue.  Secondly,
mobile technology is just hard.
People who are new to marketing
on apps I feel like are always
surprised when they realize
there aren't cookies on apps.
You've got advertising
identifiers, IDFA's, they don't
work well with cookies on mobile
web, so the technology that was
designed to help us connect
with our users often actually
ends up getting in the way, and
not to mention of course the App
Stores, right?  Google Play and
the App Store, they add a step
in between giving our users an
ad or something like that and
actually discovering the app, so
it's one step or three
depending on how you look at it.
So this creates a Clouding
marketing picture at best.  And
then finally, I feel like we're
drowning in tools.  Every time I
meet a developer, I always ask
them, what Analytics tools are
they using?  Almost certainly
they rattle off four or five
different Analytics tools
they're using, and they're using
all of them, they're just using
them for different things.  So
they could have an SDK for
tracking crash reporting or one
for tracking push notifications
or behavioral in-app Analytics
or conversion tracking.  So each
one of these SDK's in and of
themselves aren't that big,
aren't that much work to add,
but when you start adding them
all together, that's four or
five SDK    SDK's for different
types of Analytics that you're
use ng your app.  -- use ng your
app.  When you look at them all
together, they could add bloat
to app, and certainly as
developers I know we don't like
adding extra code every time a
marketer asks for another tool.
That's just looking on the
development side, but when
you're actually
consuming that data in the UI,
you've got different databases,
different systems and these
different data silos don't speak
well together.  They were never
designed to work together, so
you end up making your decisions
in a couple of different
disparate places.  And that's
why we are bringing to you
Firebase Analytics and Firebase,
because we're really trying to
do something different by
offering this platform.  So
unless you've been living under
a rock for the last few days,
you should know that Firebase is
a suite of integrate ed
products that we're introducing
to help you develop your app,
grow your user base, and earn
money.  And Firebase Analytics
is really at the core of this
platform.  I thought it was
pretty impressive the way that
this designer designed this
graphic, quite literally
Analytics is at the core of this
image, but not only is it
connecting all of the different
products within Firebase
Analytics, but it helps you
understand each phase of the
customer journey so that you can
really get an end to end
picture of what's going on in
your app.  Now, adding Firebase
to your app is as simple as 1,
2, 3.  1 is registering your app
on Firebase.com so you can
actually create that instance
within our second.  Secondly,
you're given a configuration
file which you'll be adding to
the app.  And third, you add two
lines of code on iOS and you
just adjust your configuration
file on Android and just like
that you're up and running with
Firebase.  This is a one-time
task that you would do to
instrument any of the features
in Firebase, but no matter which
feature you're implementing,
you will get Firebase Analytics
by default, so it's a pretty
easy way to get up and running
to immediately start asking
questions of your data.  Now, I
see Firebase Analytics being
particularly helpful in three
different ways.  First of all,
it's completely free and
unlimited          unlimited.
When we set out a while ago to
completely redesign an app
Analytics product from the
ground up, free and unlimited
was one of our founding tenets.
We wanted to make sure that you
as developers had access to all
of your data without compromise
, so no hit limits, no sample
ing, and it's your data.  This
was built by the knowledge of
the developers and product
managers of Google Analytics for
apps, so we were able to take
learnings from several years and
hundreds of thousands of apps
to take what we have and the
feedback that we've been getting
from our users to truly build
an app Analytics product that is
built for app developers.  And
then we have automatic event
reporting.  So with Firebase
Analytics, immediately after
plugging in the SD-K you're
getting over -- plugging in the
SDK, you're getting over 12
automatic events captured
automatically.  You can log into
your dashboard and see a bunch
of information without logging
any additional information.  But
if you're new to Analytics,
maybe you don't know exactly how
to instrument your app, we also
give you guides for different
verticals about what we
recommend to instrument in your
app.  Different events that we
suggest you captured
capture.  And this can be used,
of course, as a guide if you're
new tolytic, but it is also
helpful because we give -- if
you're new to Analytics, but it
is also helpful because we give
you dedicated reporting for
specific events.  If you have a
specific retail event, we'll
give you a report for that, or a
specific game event, again,
we'll give you a dedicated
report for that since we
understand the context, the
syntax of that event, those
parameters, we'll make sure to
give a report that makes sense
in the context of that event.
And then finally, Firebase
Analytics is seamlessly
integrate ed with the rest of
Firebase, and it's not just seam
less p integrated with the rest
of Firebase, it's also integrate
ed across Google.  Again,
integration was one of our
founding tenets of Firebase
Analytics, isn't we knew that
developers are instrumenting,
you know, they could have 14
different developer tools in
their app, again, they don't
speak to each other, and what we
wanted to do with faibdz was
have a single -- with Firebase
was to have a single platform
where you could come to one
single place to do all the
developer tasks.  Integration is
a key point I'll dive into a
little more later.  And of
course Firebase Analytics works
on both iOS and Android.  Since
we know that successful app
developers are building on both
platforms and we are committed
to being platform agnostic
.  Now, if you attended our
session on Wednesday, you saw
that Firebase Analytics can be
used to help develop your app,
grow your user base and earn
money, and this is really not a
linear path, right?  It's a
cycle.  So you'll be taking each
one of these actions over and
over, rinse, repeat.  But right
now in this session we'll be
talking about Firebase Analytics
in the context of growth and
how you can actually use it to
augment your marketing strategy
.  We're going on look at it in
the context of a real app.  So
we've got this app Transworld
endless skate er.  It's
available on both iOS and
Android, and it allows users to
try to attempt the longest runs
in the game, and they can select
from five different pro skate
ers that have different skills
and tricks that they have access
to.  Another thing that you can
do in this game is you can
spend on in-app purchases to
purchase virtual currency in the
game, and then once you're in
the game, you can spend that
virtual currency on other tricks
, unlock new levels or whatever.
But the important part to note
is that skates in-game
committee works.  So if we can
find more users, bring them into
the app, then Transworld end
less skate er should make more
money.  That's why we hired Mike
, this marketer.  Now, Mike
decides, Mike is responsible for
growing Transworld endless
skate er and he decides that now
is the right time to get the
app in the hands of his users.
It's right around finals time,
maybe he's looking to take
advantage of some folks who are
just getting off school and
looking to find a new game for
the summer or maybe they just
need something to procrastinate
while they're studying.  But he
thinks now is the time and he
sets a pretty ambitious goal of
300,000 installs k he's driving
around 10,000 installs, so he
has a lot of work ahead of him.
And he thinks Firebase
Analytics can help.  So he logs
into the Firebase console and
immediately when he gets here,
he notices a ton of data is
already available for him, and
this is because Mike's developer
named Andy had actually already
been using the Firebase product
for a series of other features,
so Mike never had to ask Andy
to add any new SDK because it
was already there for him, the
Analytics is already available
to him.  So he logs in, he sees
a ton of rich data, a bunch of
events are being captured
automatically, he can see his
monthly active users      users,
he can see his revenue numbers,
et cetera.  Now, he navigates
to the events section of the app
.  I like to think of event as
like the currency that Firebase
Analytics actually runs on.
These are also what I like to
describe as the verbs or action
words in the app, so things like
level up or in-app purchase,
whatever these are, and he
notices a lot of the events that
have been logged automatically
by just plugging in the SDK, so
he can see app update, he can
see OS update, session start, et
cetera, even in-app purchase,
since this is a game and
Firebase Analytics captures in-
app purchases automatically on
both iOS and Android.  And he
also notices a couple of events
that were captured by Andy that
are specific to games, so you
can see at the bottom there
spend virtual currency and
unlock achievement.  These are
two games that are specific to
games that Andy had registered,
logged in the code with just a
line or two of code, and these
actually contain pretty rich
information about games
specifically.  I had highlighted
those different vertical
specific events earlier.  These
are some examples of those.  So
if you were to click into them,
you would actually see some
reporting around them.  And then
Mike navigates to the
attribution tab, so in the
attribution tab he can see his
conversions.  The con verges are
the business drivers in his app
that he's really looking to opt
miedz his business around.
First ohm an in-app purchase, we
know these are really common in
-app event, we'll enable those,
but Mike happens the opportunity
to enable any of the events
that he has access to to be
conversions and he can do this
in the events tab on the far
right column there is an enable
conversion toggle.  By turning
those o they will add those
events to the attribution table.
Marking something as a
conversion, basically unlocks
some features and functionality
for that event.  You can do
attribution reporting, so you
can see cross-channel campaign
performance for your different
conversions.  We talked about
Mike had automatically gotten
in-app purchase and first open
but he decides to go ahead and
indicate spend virtual currency
to also be one of the conversion
tion that he wants to optimize
s
that he wants to optimize
towards.  So I want to step back
really quickly and talk about,
we've talked about the
attribution section and
generally what you can do within
Firebase Analytics but now I
want to talk about the paid part
of marketing
marketing, look at how you can
integrate Firebase Analytics
with your advertising efforts.
So Mike thans he's going to be
driving 300,000 installs, if
he's going to be spending that
much money, then he really wants
to make sure he understands the
tools that he has access to, so
that is why he wants to
basically understand what
Firebase Analytics can actually
do for him.
Now, a key part of our
integration with Firebase
Analytics has been being able to
integrate across other Google
products.  And with Firebase
Analytics, one of our most
important integrations
integrations from
day 1 has been our integration
with AdWords.  We know that if
you've run marketing cam bains
AdWords in the past,  --
campaigns with add wards in the
past, it can be difficult to
track your conversions.  We know
you have to keep track of your
conversion ID, conversion labels
, it can be a headache,
oftentimes you had to make code
changes to run a marketing
campaign and this can often
sometimes create friction
between the marketers and the
developers in a product.  So
we've been very deliberate about
actually shaping our
integration between AdWords and
Firebase.  So it comes in a
couple of different parts.  The
first part is you establish a
link between your Firebase app
and your AdWords account.  By
establishing that link, that
handshake, a bunch of features
get unlocked.  For example, you
get conversion tracking and you
can import any of the conversion
s that you had access to in
Firebase, you can track your
AdWords campaigns against them.
Then secondly         secondly,
you can also target the
audiences that you've created
using your Firebase Analytics
data in AdWords.  So a really
powerful way that shouldn't
require any code changes from
the marketing perspective, you
should be able to do everything
you need as a marketer directly
from the UI.  All right.  So
Mike decides to run some
universal app campaigns, and
universal app campaigns are an
AdWords feature that were launch
ed last year to basically make
your life as an app marketer a
lot easier.  So Google has
access to all these touch points
when users are on their mobile
phones.  Right?  There's Google
.com and users searching for
apps in Google.com.  Of course,
there's Google Play and actually
discovering those apps in the
Play Store.  We have the mobile
display network, so both on
mobile web and across other apps
and inventory and AdMob, and
then finally of course YouTube,
right?  So we have all these
different touch points and
instead of asking you as a
marketer to continue to maintain
each one of these channels and
have individual strategies for
each one of these, you can book
a campaign once with universal
app campaigns and then we will
deploy those campaigns across
all these different touch points
to remove some of the burden on
you as a marketer.  So from
past experience, Mike knows that
universal app campaigns are
pretty effective at running cost
-      cost-efficient CPI's,
but basically he knows this
could be a good approach to
actually acquiring some of those
300,000 users that he has as a
goal.  So the first thing ahe's
going to do, as we talked about
earlier, log into AdWords, he's
going on link his AdWords
campaign with his Firebase, he's
going to link his AdWords
account with his Firebase
project.  So this is a one-time
task and then the rest of his
campaigns and data will flow
seam     seamlessly.  He's going
to select which conversions to
import into AdWords and as we
highlighted on the attribution
tab, we're going to have the
first open, which is baiivelg
like installs,
basically like installs,
driving installs, secondly,
he's going to be reporting his
in-app purchases, so it's the
items being purchased in the app
, then finally it's that third
conversion, the spend virtual
currency conversion.  Even
though he's focused on driving
installs, those are like first
opens, he still wants to import
all of the conversions that he
has access to since those are
good signs of engagement and he
would like to measure the
performance of his ad campaigns
across those in-app events as
well as his first opens.  So
he's linked a AdWords account,
he's imported the conversions he
cares about, and then finally
later on we'll look at an
example of him actually using re
-marketing campaigns for the
audiences that he has access to.
All right.  But Mike also
knows that he doesn't want to
put all of his eggs in one
basket.  He thinks that AdWords
will be powerful, but he doesn't
want to bet on that entirely.
So that's why he's also running
campaigns with a couple of other
networks.  So within Firebase
Analytics on the attribution
section, which is going to be
the homepage basically for any
marketer using the product, he
can go into the network settings
tab and access over 20 major ad
networks to run campaigns with,
so they don't have to be Google
networks.  These are other
networks that we as Firebase are
partnering with.  He goes ahead
and sets up a campaign for
advise.  Now, advise is a
hypothetical ad network, but he
knows or he thinks it could be
successful, and there's a couple
of different steps.  First of
all, he's going to generate a
tracking URL that's available to
him within the Firebase URI and
this tracking URL he'll be able
to send over to Advise and it
will include a lot of the
metadata that we need to do
click tracking with Advise.  If
you ever tried to track
acquisition campaigns before,
especially if you tried to do it
with Googlelytic, this was a
Google
Analytics, this was a lot harder
to do.  Now we've embedded this
into the product and have the
integrations with a bunch of
different networks.  All you
have to do is copy and paste
this URL, put it in your ad
netted work when you're running
the campaigns and this will be
the destination, we'll do the
rest of the processing from here
.  This is for attribution
tracking.  When he logs in
attribution section later, he
would be able to see basically
all the advise installs that
he's brought in.  But if he's
doing this, then he's not
putting the Advise SDK in his
app which is of course one of
the main reasons why he's using
Firebase Analytics.  But he
knows that in order to best work
with Advise, it usually helps
if he sends data back to  Advise
, some of his conversion data so
they can actually do
optimisation in their systems.
So this is where post backs come
in, which is the ability for an
advertise er to send their
conversion data back to the ad
networks they work with.  This
is one of the main reasons you
can replace all of these ad
network S  SDK's with a single
Firebase SDK.
In Firebase you're cleking all
the data but with postbacks
you're sending it back to the
network that you're working with
.  Here in the postback section
at the bottom he slectsz the
conversions -- selects the
conversions he wants to send
back.  He's going on select all
three conversions, first opened,
spend virtual currency and in-
app purchase, and then also he
hassed option to send just the
con -- he heaps the option to
send just the conversions that
Advise is responsible for
sending him or all the
conversions with his app.  He's
feeling generous and will send
all the conversions because he
knows Advise will do the best
job optimize ing when they have
more information.
Lmplet another thing I
Another
thing I didn't tell you when he
was setting up the universal app
campaign is when he set up his
app campaign he decided to
target the U.S. and Australia,
and the reason why he did that
was because last week when Mike
was on Twitter, he saw a couple
folks in Australia mentioning
Transworld endless skate er.
When he clicked around, he was
explore ing, it turns out
there's a pretty engaged gaming
community in Australia that had
discovered Transworld endless
skate er and was pretty excited
about T however, when he
about
it.  However, when he looked at
the performance of the app in
Australia, he noticed that only
less than 10% of his users are
actually coming from Australia,
so this basically led him to
believe that maybe there's this
untapped market in Australia,
that maybe he should actually be
running more campaigns there.
Hence, why he had targeted his
universal app campaign at
Australia specifically.  To test
this hypothesis, he goes into
the audience spheafngz and
creates
and creates an audience
in Australia because efts to
analyze this segment of use ers
and see if he was right that
this could be potentially a high
value segment.  You can see
here the list of the audiences
he has access to, he just
recently created this awses
Australian users one and next
time he comes into the
experiences, he can see if his
hypothesis was, in fact, correct
.  All right.  So at this point
I want to talk about moving the
needle or moving the bottom line
.  So up until this point, I've
just been talking about more
installs, but something we
haven't been talking about is
around monetization, and
currently with Firebase
Analytics, we track revenue for
you, for the in-app purchase
event and the e-commerce
purchase event.  Threes the
transactional events we know are
revenue based so that's what's
factoring into our ARPU or into
our LTD metrics.  So Mike here
has two additional goals beyond
the installs goals that I talked
about earlier.  We had that
300,000 installs goals but he
also has an engagement metric
that he's trying to drive of
moving the daily nch aengagement
a       average
engagement up from 15 minimum
minutes to 20 minutes and
secondly has a monetization
goal of moving his ARPU from
what was originally 90 cents to
$3.  When he checks in after
he's been running these ad
campaigns, he was able to move
it up to at least $1.50, so it's
made some move am, but between
movement,
but between $1.50 and $3, he has
a lot of work to do.  So to
actually dig into figuring out
how he would better move the
needle and figure out how he
could drive up that ARPU, he
clicks into the funnel section
of Firebase Analytics and in
funnels you can create baiivelg
a visualization of -- basically
a visualization of different
events in your app and how they
relate to one another, see how
users are moving through
different parts of your user
journey.  He creates a pretty
simple funnel, this one is
called purchasers, it has only
two steps.  The first step is
users who basically ever launch
ed the appear, first open.
Second step is users who went on
to make an in app purchase.  He
creates this funnel and
realizes his conversion rate is
a very measly .3%, so not very
many people are actually place
ing purchases.  So definitely
room for improvement, he's
trying to figure out basically
how he could make a difference
on this front.  And to do this,
he comes back to the attribution
tab, he's looking at all the
relative campaign performance
next to each other and he sees
that there's one network I'm
calling stomp network here that
is performing much lower than
some of the other ones.  So it
is bringing in a couple hundred
installs, so good volume, but
when he looks at the lifetime
value metric for this particular
network, he realizes it's at
zero.
So they're bringing in
installs, but it's not really
the installs he's looking for.
So he decides to go ahead and
reallocate his funds away from
stomp network and invest them in
another place.  So that's one
thing he did to actually
hopefully bump up that ARPU
number.  We'll talk about a
couple more in a few minutes.
Now, another thing he notices is
he had run that AdWords
campaign, and over the last week
he has seen over 50% of the new
users he's been acquiring have
been from Australia, so that's
comforting, it looks like maybe,
in fact, that hypothesis was a
reasonable hypothesis that
Australia could be an untapped
market for him.  Then there's a
couple more ways that he's going
to try to move that ARPU metric
up a little bit more.  The
first is when he came into the
audience's section, he found
there was an audience named
purchasers, so this is basically
any of the users that were
purchasing in his app.  When he
clicked in, he realized that
there was actually a pretty high
distrib Ewing of his purchasers
in Japan.  This is interesting
because A, the app is not
localized in Japan, he's not
trying to do anything to drive
users in Japan specifically, and
then when he looks at just his
plain usage numbers, the
distribution of users in Japan
wasn't particularly high, but
for some reason it seems like
the users who are in Japan are
more inclined to actual purchase
.  So he decides to go ahead and
run a campaign, an acquisition
campaign, with creative
localized in Japanese, so even
though the app isn't localized
in Japanese, he wants to see if
potentially localizing his
creative in Japanese and his ad
campaigns might make a
difference to actual bring in
more Japanese users.
The second thing that he does
is creates a re   reengagement
campaign using his purchaser's
audience.
So in AdWords he setsz up a
reengagement campaign and
targets those that he already
knows have actually purchased in
the app.  So they're known
purchasers, they're users he
wants to continue to foster a
relationship with, so he sets up
a retargeting campaign for
these users specifically.  So
those are two additional things
beyond taking funds away from
stomp netted work that he's
trying to do to optimize his
ARPU.  Now it's at the end of
the month and I'm happy to
report that Mike has succeeded
in many of his goals.  So first
of all, he was able to exceed
the 300,000 installs goal that
we set out at the beginning of
the session, he was also able to
move the needle on the daily
average engagement metric, so it
had started off at 15 minutes
and now we're at 23 minutes, and
then finally for the ARPU
metric where we listed out those
couple of different things we
did to try to move the needle on
that front, he was able to move
it up to $3.30 when his initial
goal was $3.  So I'm happy to
report that Mike and his team
will be able to celebrate with
drinks tonight, much like I hope
that me and my team will be
able to celebrate with drinks
tonight asp this week
after this week.  All
right.  We talked a lot about
advertising and how Firebase
Analytics can be used for
advertising, but I also want to
highlight a couple of
ways that it can be used in
conjunction with some of your
organic tools since we know that
as a marketer you're probably
not just running ad campaigns.
That's just one of the tools
that you're use ng your toolbox,
but you've got a couple other
channels as well.  So first I
want to touch on Firebase
notifications.  Notifications
are a great way to engage in a
conversation with your users
directly, and on Firebase
Analytics they're supported on
both iOS and Android and like
Firebase Analytics they're
totally free and unlimited, so a
really powerful way tone gauge
in a conversation with your
users      users -- to engage in
a conversation with your users
directly for reengagement
purposes.  There's two
integration purposes with
analytics I want to highlight.
You can target the audience in
Firebase Analytics within
notifications, so you can be
serving them experiences that
make sense in that context.
Then also you can use Firebase
Analytics to actually understand
how your campaigns performed.
So how many notification opens
did you get?  How many opens did
you actually drive with a
particular push notification?
Or for users that came in on a
particular campaign
campaign, what did their
behavior look like once they
entered the app?  You can apply
that as a filter throughout the
Firebase experience, throughout
the Firebase Analytics
experience, to actually stee how
users who came from a
particular notification then
went on to navigate your app.
You can also measure it against
your conversions, so how many in
-app purchases did a particular
campaign drive.  Second type of
organic channel I want to
highlight is the app invites.
App invites are a great way to
facilitate the relationship
between your users and their
contacts         contacts, so
it's not just about you and your
users and that relationship but
actually facilitate ing a
bigger network.  So again, you
can use Firebase Analytics to
identify groups that you would
want to actually notify, reach
out to, target those users, and
then give them the opportunity
to share the app using SMS or
e-mail to bring in their most
frequently contacted users.  Of
course you can pair this with
dynamic links, which I know
there's been a couple other
sessions for, where you could
actually take users to a
specific screen in the app once
they've clicked through on a
download.  Then finally, we
have app indexing.  So Google
has indexed over 100 billion
deep links and 40% of all
Android query ies return app
links.  So basically this is an
incredible opportunity for
exposure for marketers to
actually help users find content
within their apps.  So you can
imagine initially when apps were
create ed, apps were very much
walled gardens and in some cases
they still can be, but with
features like app inteking,
we're really looking to help our
users discover the content
within the app without actually
having to navigate through the
full app to experience that.
This is particularly powerful
when it comes to reengagement
and trying to get your known
users back into the app.
There's a couple of different
companies that I think have done
this really well that I want to
highlight.  These are three
different examples of apps and
these are all search engine
results page.  So you can
imagine this is basically what a
user would see, and here are
these blue dots, are aware the
user would actually be using.
First we have the realtor.com
app and the query in Google here
is I think homes for sale in
Sunnyvale, so when I click on
that line item at the top here,
I get taken inside the realtor
.com app to a map focused on
Sunnyvale, able to see all of
the homes for sable.  So pretty
cool that I as a user had to do
no additional work beyond
clicking, and I'm in the app,
it's a much more rich experience
and it's exactly what I set out
to look for in the first place.
All right.  Here in the middle
I have an example of me
searching for the restaurant
Cook ri in San Francisco and
when I click on the trip advisor
link I'm taken directly to that
listing in the  Trip Advisor
app, I can see the reviews for
that particular restaurant.
Then finally on the right I have
the Expedia app, I'm looking at
hotels in Tokyo and similar to
the homes in Sunnyv
Sunnyvale, I'm taken into the
app and can see a map with all
of the available hotels.  So
pretty powerful way to get our
users exactly what they want
with a ton of context while
making them do very little work.
So enough from the PM on
Firebase Analytics about why
Firebase is so great.  I want to
let you hear from a couple of
our app developers who have been
using some of the tools as well
.  So I think actually Joe is
here in the audience, he's from
Spark People.  Joe is right over
here.  So Joe shared with us
the ability to sync his AdWords
data to Firebase Analytics has
simplified his daily management
and optimisation from hours to
minutes.  So he can spend more
time building an app that his
users will love.  I would love
to have hours back in my day, so
I wish somebody would do this
for my job.  Pretty cool to see
how building these types of
tools can make      basically
create more time for the app
developers to do the thing they
actually want to do rather than
the thing they need to do
because tools are making them do
T we also had recruit, which is
a Japanese company, using the
integration between AdWords and
Firebase and one of the
marketing managers over on that
front had e-mailed us that
AdWords and Firebase Analytics
just work better together.
So we difficulty Firebase
Analytics to be a great engine
for you guys as marketers, so
you can develop and grow your
user base whether you consider
yourself a developer or a
marketer.  As a quick recap of
this conversation, I covered a
couple of different things.
First I highlighted Firebase
Analytics in general, then we
talked about how you could
actually use it to track your
tition or paid channels, and
then -- your advertising or paid
channels, and finally we
wrapped up by talking about some
of the organic or non
advertising channels that you
could use Firebase Analytics
with.  So as we've been crafting
Firebase Analytics, we've been
very deliberate about building a
tool that would work well not
just for developers but also for
marketers, so we're really
excited to see what you guys
will do with this.  Thank you
you.
(applause)
.
So I have about five
minutes in case anybody wants to
ask questions.  I think you can
use the mic if you want to come
and ask a question.
>> Hello. We used the
Firebase SDK about two months
ago and launched one month ago.
After I connected, I found a
problem that it only connects
with the Android account under
my Gmail.  So it's one to one,
not one to many, because in
China, for example, developers,
we have a lot of agencies to run
campaigns in different accounts
, so what I want is one account,
one Firebase account to reflect
to many, many accounts but I
don't want to give permission to
Firebase.  So that's my
question.  I don't know when we
are part of this venture.
>> FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Great question.  I have a
couple answers to it.  First,
you should be able to link a
Firebase account to multiple
AdWords account.  It is not one
to one.  It is one to many.  And
you should be able to thring on
a bunch.  We also have
(Please stand by for the
Google I/O session A
Window into Transitions.)
(Standing by for the Google
I/O session A Window
into Transitions.)
(Please stand by.  The
Google I/O session A Window
into Transitions will begin
shortly.)
(Please stand by.  The
session is about to begin.)
(Applause.)
>> Hello, everyone. Thank
you very much for
coming to this talk, A Window
into Transitions.  It's
one of the last talks of I/O or
the ultimate talk.
My name is Nick Butcher.  I'm
joined by Ben Weiss and
George Mount.  We are on the
Android engineering team
team.  Okay?
(Applause.)
>> NICK BUTCHER: We are
here today to talk about
the Android Transition API.  We
have a lot to cover.
We will jump into the topic and
get going.  First up,
Transitions, what are they?
The basic idea of the
Transition API is to help you
whenever there is a
scene where it is a view
hierarchy on screen.  The
idea is that when a scene
changes, my animation
doesn't work properly, iron
ically, and we perform a
Transition, Transition being
look at what has changed
and an mate that difference.
So the API for the
Transition is pretty simple.
It is exactly this thing.  What
has changed?  Firstly
there will be two call backs
into your Transition
which is capture stop values
and capture end values.
This is a value object.  This
object has the view.
You can look at the view and
capture properties about
it and save it into the map.
And I do that in a
start state and end state and
then we will call the
create an mate er method giving
those two states and
you create an mate ors to an
mate the change between
the two states.  So that's the
very basic API.  There
There's a bunch of trgs which
come in the Android
framework which you can and
should use.  You can see
what the primitives you can
build with are.  The
change balance Transition is
the first.  This will
help you out whenever you are
moving or resizing a
view.  It will an    an mate
the first and cop properties.
Crucially this helps suppress
layout.  You don't want
to call request layout parole.
Change balance will
do this in a performing way.
Secondly, fade
transition, which helps fades
in and out.  Any time
an object visibility changed or
gets added or removed
from the hierarchy you can do a
fade.
There is an auto transition
which puts some of
those things together.  When a
hierarchy changes
you
fade newly arriving things in,
move and resize items
in a changing position and fade
out anything that is
disappearing.
In API 21, lollipop,
Transition API got a bunch of
new and exciting additions.
First was the slide.  So
you can, any time anything is
entering or exiting a
scene you can do it from the
edge in a staggered
manner.  There are a bunch of
transforms whenever you
are changing the bounds.  You
can click the bounds of
something changing size or with
doing a change
transform which will affect the
rotation and scale of
a view or doing an image, say
you're changing from
one scale type to another, this
changes the matrix of
the view between those scales.
The transitions object
itself got upgrades in 21.
Firstly it got this thing
called path motion which
allows you to control the
movement along a path.  So
here, for example, we are look
ing at a transition
which is a shared element.  We
can control the path
that it follows when moving
from one state to another
another.  Don't do this
horrible loopy thing.  This
is exaggerated for effect.
Please don't do that.
The class you'll probably
want to look at when
doing this control the path is
called arc motion and
pattern park motion and we'll
get to those later.
Now we have the controlled
propagation and Epi
center.  What the properties
let you do is core graph
the way things will move.  In
this example when I
click on an item, see how the
views around the grade
move together.  This is called
explode transition.
Basically by passing in the ep
center, you can set
the start glades on the other
views in order to have
a coordinated movement.  These
are the APIs to look
for if you try to build this
kind of transition
yourself.
So that's Transitions.  It
turns out that quite
frequently when changing scenes
, once you perform an
animation on those changes, it
is activity boundary.
Going from one to another.  API
21 added new APIs to
do this kind of thing which we
call Windows
Transitions.  There are two
main types.  First is a
content Transition.  That's
when a window exits or a
new window enters, you have an
opportunity to run on
the content coming in.  We go
from the grid and
launch into a detail screen, we
enter animation on
the views coming into the
details where they are
sliding in from the bottom.
Second time is a shared
element Transition.  So this is
where -- oops, went
too far.  Go back.
There.  Okay.  Shared
element is where when you
tap on one view, the element
transitions smoothly
from one activity into the
second activity.  As you
had a sneak peek those two
things aren't mutually
exclusive.  You can, of course,
run a shared element
and content and transition as
well.  Here we are
sharing a view and also sliding
in the unshared
content as it were.
Now I know on shared element
views, shared element
Transitions, you can't actually
share a view between
two activity ies.  You can't
pick up one view from one
activity and surplant it into
another one.  As many
APIs do, they fake it, allow
you to give the
appearance of what is happening
while maintaining
either one activity or another.
The way we do it,
when you click on an image in
the source activity we
record some information about
that view.  This one,
there's position, bounds, a few
other things.  We
pass that information over to
the destination
activity.  So we then launch
the destination activity
but don't show anything just
yet.  Then we lay out a
and measure all the views in
the destination activity
and lay out where that shared
activity wants to end
up.
Then we apply ied transforms
to the destination view
to put it back into the
position it was in in the
source view and then fade out
any unshared content.
So at this point, destination
activity is launched.
It is an activity on top, but
it appears as if you
are still in the source
activity because it's being
transformed.
Then we simply run animation
s to move the shared
element back into place and
fade back up any unshared
content.  It looks like you sh
ared one activity to
another.  But this is important
to remember,
everything happens in the
destination activity.  You
are never changing the view in
the source activity
other than hiding it.
So shared element and
content Transitions can run
a number of points.  So there's
a kind of lifecycle
to think about here.  Go from
one screen to another,
call start actively you have an
opportunity to run
Transitions on the exiting
source activity and the
entering destination activity.
On the way back you
can animate on the reenter.
These are the four
points you can look at.  They
come in payers.  If
you
set an exit Transition, do
something with the views
on the way out, by default if
you don't specify a
different reenter, it will run
the same Transition in
reverse.  So bear in mind that
's what is going on
there.
That in a nutshell is what
the Transition API is
trying to do.  To give you an
example how to do it,
Ben will walk through an
application that will
implement these APIs.
>> BENJAMIN WEISS: Thank
you, Nick.  We had a
couple of Transitions going on
there.  And let's see
what we are going to do now.
We will have an
application having a mass
activity and a detail
activity.  Once you tap on one
of the items it will
move the image and promote a
couple other Transitions
the let's get started.
We have the app.  Before we
actually got started
with the Transitions, this is
what system gives us.
We tap upon the views.  And the
detail activity
Slides and fades in.  Pretty
cool.  But in order to
produce, use the Transitions
API what we want to do
is first enable the window
activity Transitions
within our app theme or simply
from theme material or
as many of you use it, a.m.
come Pat is also inherits
from theme material on lollipop
and +
.
Once we got this we can go
to the next step and do
the shared element Transition
for the image view.  In
order to do this we set a
Transition name on both the
starting and the target view
and remember those
should be at least unique for
the view hierarchy ies in
order to avoid lishes we will
talk about later on.
After we have taken a look
into this we need to
tell the system how to actually
deal with the shared
element.  As we just learned
sharing the element is
something that happens within
the receiving or detail
activity.  So we have to tell
the system that at the
point where we actually start
the new activity that a
couple of things have changed.
We make the scene
animation pass the image that
we want to share as
well as the identify ier for
the target view, the name
that we set on there.  Cool,
straightforward and
awesome to use.
After that, we add the
exiting Transition for the
grid which is the explode that
we just saw which is
probably one of the things that
you should think
about if you actually want to
do it.  It can confuse
users.  It can be very handy as
well on the other
hand.  Don't throw explodes in
everywhere because it
can be not helpful on the other
hand as well.
So to do this we create a
Transition in Transition
exit.  We just say
explode and that's it from the
declaration of the
transaction.
Pretty straightforward again
.  We then set that in
in, we then have to declare the
window exit
Transition within our home
activity ies theme.  And as
we just learned this will be
replayed, reversed on
the way back in when the
activity, other entry
position when we press back
from the detail activity.
Let's go and take the next
step for the detail
activity.  We also want the
content that is not
shared to be, to slide in from
the bottom.  You can't
just create the transitions
from XML.  You can do
this directly within code.
Let's take a look how you
can do that.  We just created a
new slide Transition.
We want to have the contents
slide in from the bottom
bottom.  We want to have it
enter full smeed and ease
up until it reaches the resting
point.  To do this we
inflate an ininterpreter plate
er to do that.  On the
window parse activity we setted
the enter transition
to be the Transition we just
created.  This can be a
lot more complex if you want to
, but we got started
with one Transition seeing if
you have things in
place and it works pretty well.
Since we are in the motion
of getting things feel
more natural by having them
enter quickly, let's took
a look at what Nick mentioned,
curve motion.  Usually
you have one linear motion of
the shared element view
view, but we want to have this
motion so it feels
while the -- while the view is
growing, it should
also have a curved path that it
follows to make it
more natural.
Let's take a look at one of
the Transitions that
we used there.  We have a
Transition set which is a
collection of different
Transitions that will be run
at a point in the animation.
And we basically just
have to do this on the set
bounds.  We say we want to
add arc motion to that.  Pretty
straightforward again
again.
And it helps to get exactly
this done.  You can
also set maximum/minimum angle
for that and make sure
that the user actually sees
what is going on.  You
shouldn't exaggerate like Nick
earlier said.  But for
development purposes this can
be pretty handy.
So those are all build in
Transitions.  Let's look
at what we can do to get into
custom Transitions.  We
want to share the detailed text
.  The title, the
author of the picture.  We did
a couple of things
there other than just growing,
just sharing that.  We
also grow it and to do this
from the declaration
point of view, we just go back
to the Transition that
we already had, add a target to
both of the
Transition to have the initial
Transition set only
target the photo that we
already shared.  Then we go
and add a second Transition set
targeting the author
that we want to share as women
and add a text resize
Transition to that which is a
custom transition that
George will cover in a minute.
And then, of course,
we need to tell the system what
is going on and that
things have changed.  So far we
shared the image and
the target directly.  If you
only have one shared
element, this is a good way to
actually get started
with that, to share this
information with the detail
activity.
If you have multiple shared
elements, though, you
want to have pairs which can be
traded in -- treated
in separate ways.  You create a
pair which contains
the same information.  It
contains the detail, the
starting view as well as the
target transition name.
And then instead of having this
on here, you just
pass those two pairs in here
and start the activity
as is.
And after all this is done,
this is the nice
Transitions that you get.  And
with that, let's take
a look behind the curtain.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: All right.
How is that fire
host, everyone?  Good?  Let's
drink some of more!
Let's talk about making your
own Transitions.  We saw
the built in ones, change bound
s, change, transform,
those ones.  Those are great
basic Transitions.  If
you want to change the text
size, for example, it is
not built in.  We have to do
that ourselves.  Let's
see how we go about making this
.  Make resize text
Transition.
All right.  So we need to
capture some data, right
right?  We need, of course, the
font size.  That's
obvious, right, capture the
font size at the begin
beginning, the end, and we also
need other data.
But when we return the data
set that we are going
to track in our Transition, we
only want, only care
about the font size.  If other
stuff changes, the
bounds changes only on your
text view we are not
going to do any Transition on
that.  We are only
Transitioning when the text
size changes.  We ignore
the rest of the data.  We still
want to capture it.
That's why we have those pieces
of information, that
tag that we are going to use in
the Transition values
values.  But we don't want to
keep that for the
Transition API, the Transition
framework.
So when we capture our start
values and end values
values, remember from what Nick
said, we want to
capture them.  This is the same
thing in both the
start and the end.  We have a
common function to do.
And first thing we have to do,
we can throw away
anything that is not in text
view, right?  We are
only editing text views.
Anything else we ignore.
Of course we want to capture
the font size, text size
here and some other data.  I
stuck it all in its own
class and hide that information
, but it's basic
things like the bounds of the
text view.  We need
that for the animation.  When
you animate text, what
do we do?  An mate      animate
the font says?  Every font size
between the start and the end
is going to be used and
created in our font cache.  We
will have font size
26.281.  And, you know, we are
never going to use
that again.  It's going to
thrash our font cache.  We
don't want to do that.
We'll capture a bitmap at
the   front and end and
then animate.  If we animate
just the start, it looks
terrible.  You see that thing
blown up from the begin
beginning.  And also if you
animate just from the
large size down you end up with
a little bit of churn
churning error in the final
text view.  You may not
see it on this slide but you
definitely see it when
you look at the phone and you
don't want your users
to see that effect.  You want
to see a perfect
transition.  Instead of this
what we are going to do,
we are going to animate piece-
wise.  We an mate a
little bit from the start.  You
don't really see that
blown up image, right?  Then we
are going to swap it
out for the final image, scale
ed down, an animate the
rest of the way.
Because it's done during the
motion, nobody will
see that animation, that change
, that swap there in
the middle.
Okay?  Let's see how we do
that.  Clear the
animateor.  We use our start
values and end values,
but here we are checking the
start values for null.
What does null mean?  It means
the view didn't exist.
If the view didn't exist in the
beginning or the en, we
don't want to animate size.
That's for fade, right?
The other transitions.
Okay?  Next thing we have to
do, of course, is
capture the start bitmap.  We
capture that bitmap.
That's where the extra data is
useful.  We have to
capture the end state bitmap
and of course we have to
say don't text view, don't draw
yourself.  Set
yourself to transparent.  All
that text stuff, make
it transapparent.  We don't
want you to draw it
because what we are going to do
is creat a drawable
with the bitmaps we capture ed
that is going to do the
swapping for us.
So we need to an mate some t
hings on the drawable.
One of them is the font size.
We are going to have
the font size we're going to
animate on the drawable.
Animate all the other things,
the data I capture ed.
We need to know that stuff.  We
get property value
holders for those and then we
create the animateor,
right?  Then we're set to
return, right?
Not quite.  Remember what we
just did?  We set it
to be invisible.  No text?
When the animation is
done, we want it to go back to
the normal set.  We
set text color back to normal
and remove the overlay
we just added.  So we're all
set.  The transition
looks great.  All set.  Put it
in activity Transition
Transition.  What does it look
like?
Holy molely!  Did you do
this?  All right.  No, no
no, okay.  Remember what
happened, what Nick was
saying about this.  The values
are capture ed in the
destination activity.  And when
the values are
captured in the destination
activity, text view
doesn't have the text size of
the source activity's
text.  It doesn't even know
that it was there.  It
doesn't know what that font
size was.  What we have
to do is send that along as
extra data.  Now, the
activity Transitions system
will send the basic stuff
for you.  It will send you
position, size, and image
scale, right?  Those are common
things and things
built into the system.  The
Transitions are built
into the system.  The other
stuff, anything you need
to animate, you will have to
send along as well.  So
we put those in as intent extra
s.  That's easy enough
enough.  We get that intent
extra in the target
activity and we get the font
size and then we call
this shared element callback.
The shared element
callback is where you put the
complex part of your
activity transaction.  This is
a callback that has
stuff for you to look into to
do the tweaking you
need to do.  During the start
what we have to do, of
course, is capture the text
size of the current text
view and then set it to the one
that we want it to be
in the start.
And then in the end we have
to reset the text size
back to what it was before.
Otherwise you just
animate to the little tiny font
from the start.
So what happens now?  You
end up with a beautiful
transition from activity to
activity.
Nice and smooth.
Now, we are going to come
back and show this
awesome transition that he made
up.  You guys have to
see this.
>> NICK BUTCHER: Thanks,
awesome.  Those are cool
Transitions we looked at so far
.  One of my favorite
things in the updated motions
guidelines is the
section on transforming things.
If you haven't seen
this I highly recommend you
check out this and also
the awesome session in I/O on
Wednesday about the
updated Transition guidelines.
This talks about
material design, sheets of
digital paper and so on.
Transforming from one thing to
another.  This
Transition colt my eye which is
a transforming a
floating action by in circular
fab into a different
sheet of material.
And I thought this was
pretty cool and want the to
use this in an Open Source app
I built called plat
and I wanted to transform from
this into this bottom
sheet, essentially a linear
layout.  Unlike the
Transitions we've looked at so
far which are acting
on the same kind of view,
Transitions an image view
in one window or text view to
text view, this is
different, right?  We are going
to go from a floating
or image button to a linear
layout essentially.  How
do we do that?
So it is really important to
remember as we talked
about before that everything
happens in the
destination window.  In the
window this with bottom
sheet here.
So as with most animation
things we do some tricks
to make it look like one thing
is transforming into
the other.  What we do is in
the destination window
we set translation X and Y.
Basically center the
dialogue on the coordinates of
the fab, where it
started from, translation X and
Y.  We use the view
overlay again.  If you haven't
used it, this is the
ability to add drawables on top
of the view.  We add
a solid color drawable as well
as an icon on top of
the view and locate that in the
center.  And then we
run animations on this entire
view.  So first we fade
out the color and the icon.  We
run a circular reveal
animation that apply ies a
circular clipping mask and
start from the size of the fab
and animate that clip
mask out to show the whole
dialogue.
And at the same time we move
a long a curved path
using this motion thing.
So when we run all of those
animations at the same
time, you get this effect.  It
looks like you're
transforming from the fab to
the dialogue.  So you
want to see how we build this?
Okay.  About of we do, let's
think about what
information we need to build it
.  In order to build
this transition we need to know
the positions, where
the fab is to where the
dialogue is, we need to know
the color and the icon.  As we
talked about and
hammer on about, it all happens
in the destination
window.  The sheet doesn't know
anything about the
fab, right?  How do we get all
this information?
So the position is pretty
easy.  As George said
the position is one of the few
things that does
actually get passed through.
In the capture star and
capture end bounds we do the
same thing.  We have
capture values and put those
bounds into the
Transition values map and we
will get access to those
a bit later on.  We have the
bounds
of the fab and
the dialogue.  For the color
and the icon, I
basically created a couple of
constructtors you can
use.  So just like views,
Transitions can have, be
inflated from XML.  When we
looked at the XML
Transition sets we were showing
you before, define
your own Transitions as we did
with the text resize
but also add your own
attributes.  For example, we
are doing contain start ats
abuse and you can define
your class of style ables and
pull it out of the
attribute.  We can pass in the
color and the icon for
the attributes.
A quick note.  We are
setting the path motion here
here.  This is what we talked
about before, adding a
path motion to control the end
path which is going to
be along later.  We'll come
back to using that in a
second.
As an alternative, I also
added a dynamic way of
determining this.  There is
actually different entry
points that I have into the
screen.  So I couldn't
statically declare in the
details activity what color
an icon it it was going to come
from, because it can
come from multiple places in
that screen.  I added a
constructtor which will pass in
the colors the icons
use
.
So we can do the tech yeek
that George talked
about earlier, intent extras to
pass this -- here is
the path I found helpful for
implementing this.  This
isn't a path from the API
contract, this is on to the
Transition it self, called
extras.  You can call this
from the source activity, from
the activity which has
the fab and knows about the
icon and the color.  So
passing those things in a
static method and it will
add them to the extras for you
and a corresponding
setup method I called which you
call from the
destination activity.  From the
activity with the
bottom sheet which will then
pull those activity ies,
those parameters out of the
intent extra fill fields
and then it will actually
create an instance of this
Transition object which I
called transform itself,
set the target and set it on
the window has     as the shared
element enter.  I like this
path because it means it
keeps the keys and so on
private to the Transition.
You don't have to worry about
expose ing that.  It
keeps it encapsulated.
Notice we are using shared
element Transition.  If
you remember from the animation
it goes from the fab
to sheet as well as an mating
from the sheet back
down.
What that means, the shared
enter Transition was
going to get used on the return
Transition as well.
So that is going to become
important in a second.
We created a Transition
object itself.  How do we
create the animate ers to make
this all happen.  We
grab out the bounds that we
saved into the Transition
Transitions values map and hold
on to those.  I do
something, I check basically
which of those is wider.
Is it maybe not the most
sophisticated method, but
that's how I work out if I'm
going from the fab to
the dialogue or dialogue to the
fab.  I'll use that
later on to set up the
appropriate animation.  If
you're going from fab to sheet
you do an expanding
circular view or there the
sheet to the fab, you do a
contracting circular hide.
So next up, the view is
always the end value view.
Even though you give the start
and end values you're
acting on the end values of
view.  Something that
took me awhile to get my head
around, that view is
always in the state that it
ends up in which is to
say when we were going from the
fab to the dialogue,
it was already laid out and
positioned in the
dialogues position.  We
reversed it by setting those
translations and so forth to
put it back into the fab
fabs position.  It's already in
the end state.  The
same is true when I'm going
back.  What that means,
when I'm about to do the
animation from the dialogue
back to the fab, the dialogue
is actually laid out
like this, in the exact same
bounds as the fab.  What
you need to do is to manually
call measure and layout
on to the dialogue in order to
put it back into the
position that you want to
animate from.  It may sound
counter intuitive that you have
to call layout
yourself, but that's how the
system works.  It was
easy for us on the way in, but
we have to do a little
bit more work on the way back.
I just want to highlight the
translation as well.  we use
the path motion.  We set the
path
motion in the constructtor
early on.  Here I'm using
an over load of object an mate
er which will animate
two properties as once.  Here X
and Y of the dialogue
dialogue.  We get hold of that
path motion again and
call get path, that will
generate the curved path an
an mate the translation on the
curved plus for us.
We do more animateos and put
them in a set and
that gives you that entire
animation.  That's how it
it's done.  This is all Open
Source as well.  There
will be a link at the end if
that you can take a look
at the end if you want to look
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
at the nitty gritty
details.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: That was
awesome!
(Applause.)
>> GEORGE MOUNT: Let's talk
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
about a few things I
think you guys will find useful
here.  Transition
names.  Now, if you do things
well with Transition
names, the system will work for
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
you.  That will help
you a lot.  For example, we
have an animation here, a
Transition to go from this
little guy to a big thing.
Actively Transition like that.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
And what is happening in our
activity Transition
is, of course, we call, make
scene Transition
animation.  We have this view.
My view doesn't have
a Transition name here.  Or
please don't do this.
You call view.settransition
name right here in this
call.  Don't do that!  I'll
tell you why.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
We have our activity here.
We launch a new one.
And then we change the or
orientation of the phone.
What happens now?  That's
right, our activity gets
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
rebuilt.  But further, the
thing underneath it gets
rebuilt too.  Even if you
called view.settransition
just lost that.  It's
gone.  Now when the view tries
to come back, it has
no idea which is the shared e
lement.  The Transition
name is used to identify which
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
-- going from the
source to the target.  So it
can map those two.  If
it loses that Transition name
it won't know what to
do.  You of course can fix it
up and we'll talk about
that later, but the Transition
name is your friend.
So in a system like this
where you have a recycle er
view, for example, when you
bind your view, that's
when you set your Transition
name and it should be a
unique name that you have for
that item.  It can be a
URL or whatever you want.  It's
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
fine, as long as it's
a string that is unique.  Here
I bound it to the
position, in my position the
holder is unique.  Or in
data binding, you can doit in
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
the view too in data
binding.  That's awesome.  I
know some guy that works
on that.
Let's talk about changing
the shared elements.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
That means we have a different
shared element than
you originally thought.  Here I
have a view, an
activity that launches another
one and we scroll in
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
the detailed view.  When we go
back, we want to go
book to a different shared
element, right?  Now, this
Transition system of course is
going to try to go
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
back to the same one you had
before.  We have to tell
it something else.  Step one,
when you launch the
activity, ask for which shared
element is coming back
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
back.  So you start activity
for result.  Step two,
before you go back, set the
result.  Tell it which
shared element is going to come
back to you.  Here I
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
have an ID I'm going to send
back as a result.
Set three, on reactivity
reenter, not on activity
result -- I've gotten bit by
this just yesterday, I
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
think it was, when I was
writing a demo.
On activity reenter, that's
a new thing just for
activity trgs here.  It will be
called before the
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
shared element comes back.
This is where you can do
some tweaking.  Here I'm going
to get the data, the
shared element.  Okay?  That's
going to come back to
me.  All that data is coming
back to me.  Then we can
also call a shared element exit
element.  The shared
element for the exit?  The exit
is used for the
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
exiting and also for reenter,
same call back used for
both.  This is where we can
switch up our activity ies,
our shared elements.  We can
set our shared element
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
to whatever we want in our view
hierarchy.  Here I
used the ID I just got before
from the activity
reenter and used it right now
for my, to change my
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
shared element.  And now it
works perfectly.
Let's talk about overlays.
Shared elements often
go into the overlay.  If it
will go right into the
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
over
overlay unless we specifically
tell it not to.  The
great thing about this, it is
thrown on top of
everything, right?  You don't
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
want to have your
shared element drawn under
something over there,
right?  It is also clipped by
the parent.  That's
really important.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
The problem is it's drawn on
top of everything.
When it's drawn on top of
everything there's a little
bit of a problem.  And ... it
is also not clipped by
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
the parent.
Sorry, it's ... all right.
>> NICK BUTCHER: Here is a
real example I of this
issue.  In this screen when you
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
click on a list item,
I want to have this expand and
grow out.  I had a
shared element where
the back      background was
one of the
shared element.  If you
Transition two shared element
from one to the other
but the background positions to
give that growing
effect.  This is all well and
good, but if you use
the overlay to do the
Transition, if you put the
background into the overlay it
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
's on top of everything
else.  You get a horrible
effect where it grows up
and it snaps in.  That's not
what we want.  We want
the content to come in on top
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
of the background.
Hopefully we can control that,
George.  George George
yes, we can.  All we have to do
to make the shared
element do something different
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
is tell it not to.  We
set this value in your styles.
But you might end up with a
little bit of a
problem.  Ugghh.  I think it
was you, you did it,
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
right?  No.
Well, the problem is this.
Let's see what's going
on here.  The shared element is
, of course, popped
into the new activity.  And
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
when that happens, it is
being clipped by its parent and
it is only visible
when the shared element slides
into the parent view.
So what we can do, of
course, is tell the parent
don't clip it.  You say tell
the parent, say set the
children to false an also set
clip to padding false
as well.  Now, this might cause
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
you a little bit of
problem with your drawing.  Be
careful with this.  It
It's a performance issue.  You
might consider doing
this oxygen during your
transition.
But you can't do -- you you
have to go all the way
up because the grand parent can
also clip the child
and clip the shared element.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
That's no good.  The
other option is to do what Nick
did, put it right
into the root, into the root of
his layout as the
child of that.  Now it is not
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
clipped by anything
because the window is fine.
Now it has no clipping.  It
comes in instead of a
flash, it comes in on top just
like we want.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
All right.  Ben?
>> BENJAMIN WEISS: Cool.
So I have seen within
some of these Transitions, in
general if you work
with Transitions you also have
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
access to the window
deck nation
decorations.  Status bar,
background navigations.
What you can do, you define
the slide Transition
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
and what will happen with that
is it Slides all the
content in.  We highlighted the
status bar here to
show you what is going on.  So
it Slides the status
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
bar in as well.  Actually we
don't want to d
o this.
As you can see on the bottom on
the navigation bar,
the floor flash, it Slides up
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
as well.  So in order
to avoid this there's a couple
of ways to do this.
What you want to do is exclude
both the status bar
background and the navigation
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
bar background.  We
provided IDs as well as
Transition names for those so
you can work with them.  That
is one of the ways you
can work with it.  Obviously
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
you can do this not just
in XML as we showed you before
but also when you do
this within your code you
basically say on this
Transition exclude the target
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
and set those values to
true.
But you can also do
something a little bit more
nifty.  You can add this to the
shared element
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
Transitions.  You can have
three colors in there or
fade out stuff.  Fade them out
within a shared
element Transition.  To do this
you go all the way up
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
in the hierarchy, get the D
core and you create the
pairs.  This is the second way
you can create pairs.
It is another way into calling
that.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
And then adding them to the
shared element
Transition to actually have the
system being aware of
exactly that.  And then you get
the desire ed behavior
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
of no flashes, no exploding or
just moving a little
way status bar or navigation
bar background.
And with that, we actually
have a little room for
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
questions.  So you can start
lining up if you have
questions.  About six minutes.
Thank you very much
for being here.  It has been a
pleasure to talk to
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
you about Transitions and we
have Open Source all the
code already for the samples
that we gave here.  The
new one, the one with the image
s we just showed is on
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
splash.  You have to look in
Nick Butcher's plat if
you want to go on the advanced
things.  There's also
Topeka out there and another
example called our
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
streets.
Look at the training that we
have.  Yeah, thank
you very much.  Questions?
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
(Applause.)
>> AUDIENCE: I do have a
question.  What about
shared element transition into
dialogue fragment?
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
Because I was not able to do
that.  I tried that
and I wasn't.
>> BENJAMIN WEISS: I
haven't tried it.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: Dialogue
fragment is, the
contents are controlled by you.
Make sure to set the
style of the dialogue fragment.
I haven't tried it.
Start with that.  You should be
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
able to set the style
on fragment to enable activity
Transitions.  So if
you do that, then you should be
able to do all the
rest you need to do in order to
do the shared element
Transition.
It should work.  I'm not
sure why it is not.
>> AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
Thank you for the